Hey, Sean, Sean, Sean, you know that what's been really, I think, catching people off guard is some of our intros, no, we'll know some of our intros because they've been welcome to SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList.
嘿，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，你知道吗，我觉得真正让大家措手不及的是我们的一些开场白，不，我们知道我们的一些开场白，因为它们是欢迎来到SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。
SmartList. Hi, everybody. Hi, Jens. I'm feeling particularly lucky this morning and fortunate. Just, you know, walking to this room with my laptop knowing that- Me too. Me too. It's just, we're so, it's embarrassingly light lifting what we do here.
SmartList。大家好。你好，延斯。今天早上我感觉特别幸运，特别有福气。你知道，带着我的笔记本电脑走进这个房间，知道——我也是。我也是。我们在这里做的事情简直轻松得让人尴尬。
We get to just open up our laptops and talk to people we want to talk to that you'd otherwise have to wait in a long line, a long autograph line to speak to. I also feel very fortunate today. I was having, I'm going to be real with you guys. Uh-oh. I was having a tough morning. Music cue. Music cue.
我们只需要打开笔记本电脑，就能和我们想交谈的人聊天，而这些人你平时可能得排很长的队，排很长的签名队才能和他们说上话。我今天也感到非常幸运。我当时，我要跟你们说实话。噢，不。我今天早上过得很艰难。音乐提示。音乐提示。
Uh-oh. Tell me about the tough morning. I was just having, just everything that's going on and I was just having a very tough morning and I know that we always start joking and people don't want to listen to it but I was- About the world, you mean? I'm going to be completely honest. I was having a very tough morning today.
噢，不。跟我说说那个艰难的早晨。我只是，所有正在发生的事情，我只是度过了一个非常艰难的早晨，我知道我们总是开玩笑，人们不想听这些，但我当时——你是说关于这个世界吗？我要完全诚实。我今天早上过得非常艰难。
Did you stumble across a newspaper? I made that mistake a few times recently. Yeah. Cartoon. Cartoon. He loves Cartoon Network. I know. And every once in a while, someone will leave the TV on CNN and then, yeah, I can.
你偶然看到报纸了吗？我最近犯过几次这种错误。是的。卡通。卡通。他喜欢卡通频道。我知道。而且每隔一段时间，有人就会把电视停在CNN上，然后，是的，我就能。
I don't know. It was that and just life and everything. What's the main, what's the headline? I got a lot to choose from. Jason and I had a long conversation yesterday about it and I was just like, I woke up today and I, again, I think I mentioned it the other day, I'm a naturally optimistic person and I've been- Yeah.
我不知道。就是那个，还有生活和所有的一切。主要内容是什么？头条新闻是什么？我有太多选择了。杰森和我昨天就此进行了长时间的交谈，我当时就想，我今天醒来，而且，我再次提到，我想我前几天提到过，我是一个天生乐观的人，我一直——是的。
It's been tough and Amy said to me, my ex-wife, Amy, said, you've been, how are you feeling? You seem- And I said, I was over there yesterday. I said, I feel really irritable and she said, you know, for guys your age, depression often manifests itself as irritability and I was like, it really struck with me and I'm like, maybe I'm depressed. You're not depressed. Am I?
这很艰难，艾米对我说了，我的前妻艾米说，你一直，你感觉怎么样？你看起来——我说，我昨天在那边。我说，我感觉真的很烦躁，她说，你知道，对于你这个年纪的男人来说，抑郁通常表现为易怒，我当时就想，这真的触动了我，我在想，也许我抑郁了。你没有抑郁。我有吗？
No. I've been depressed and you would know it. It's an all-encompassing weight that you just, you're just constantly taking inventory and you're like, boy, there's just, it's sort of like, it's usually unsubstantiated. It's usually just kind of brought on by some sort of, I don't know, I'm not a scientist, but I think that there's chemical shit and all that stuff. If you're not a scientist, this fucking show is over. I will say that we'll, and then we can get light, but I will say, well, you do an incredible
没有。我抑郁过，你会知道的。那是一种包罗万象的沉重感，你只是，你只是不断地在盘点，你会想，天哪，这简直，它通常是毫无根据的。它通常只是由某种，我不知道，我不是科学家，但我认为有一些化学物质之类的东西。如果你不是科学家，那这该死的节目就结束了。我会说我们会，然后我们可以轻松一点，但我会说，嗯，你做得非常出色
job of navigating all the things that could trip you into self-loathing. You do a very good job without bearing your head in the sand of, you know, you look at those things honestly. You don't hide from them. You take them at face value, you assess them, you try to fix them and you stay very positive. Well, you've gone through these before, like I've seen you go through these, and it doesn't last very long and everybody has these. So you can't be like, up happy, positive all the way, all the time.
你出色地处理了所有可能让你陷入自我厌恶的事情。你做得非常好，没有把头埋在沙子里，你知道，你诚实地看待那些事情。你不躲避它们。你按面值接受它们，你评估它们，你试图修复它们，并且你保持非常积极。嗯，你以前经历过这些，就像我见过你经历这些一样，而且它不会持续太久，每个人都有这些时刻。所以你不能一直，一直快乐、积极。
I think it's normal to have these little moments and then you come out of them, you know, but when you're in them, you have to remember that you come out of them, that you can't. Yeah, that's the duper. Well, thank you. Thank you both. I love both of you guys very much. And also just because things aren't perfect, doesn't mean things are wrong. Doesn't mean things are bad.
我认为有这些小瞬间是很正常的，然后你会走出来，你知道，但当你身处其中时，你必须记住你会走出来，你不能。是的，那是骗人的。嗯，谢谢。谢谢你们俩。我非常爱你们俩。而且仅仅因为事情不完美，并不意味着事情是错的。并不意味着事情很糟糕。
It just means that's just life and we're all normal in that there's, you know, plenty of things that are pear-shaped and then there's other things that are perfectly round. And the ratio is what you need to look at. You just described both my body parts, body types, I keep to, I'll leave you with this because our guests are probably like, Jesus Christ, what have you stepped into? But I was thinking like, I've been really trying to do that thing of there are certain people as you guys both know in my life who have made it, there's some difficulties. And I'm like, I've got to try to make them my guru.
这只是意味着这就是生活，我们都很正常，因为，你知道，有很多事情是乱七八糟的，然后还有其他事情是圆满的。你需要看的是比例。你刚才描述了我身体的两个部位，体型，我坚持，我会留给你这句话，因为我们的嘉宾可能在想，天哪，你们到底卷入了什么？但我当时在想，我真的在努力做那件事，正如你们俩所知，我生命中有些人造成了一些困难。我在想，我必须试着把他们当作我的导师。
I have to. I have to make them my, it's the only way out. What does that mean? That I have to make them, that I learn a lot, that they are teaching me something. You know, Dawah, who's in our life, Dawah said years ago, I said, I know it's really tough for you to work with this other person. She said, yeah, I was going to quit a long time ago and I called my dad and I said, dad, I don't know if I can work with this person.
我必须。我必须把他们当作我的，这是唯一的出路。那是什么意思？我必须把他们当作，我学到了很多，他们在教我一些东西。你知道，道，在我们生命中的那个人，道几年前说，我说，我知道和你这个人一起工作真的很艰难。她说，是的，我很久以前就想辞职了，我给我爸爸打电话说，爸爸，我不知道我能不能和这个人一起工作。
They're too tough to work with. And her dad said to her, Dawah, how will you ever learn patience if you don't have someone to teach you? Yeah. And I was like, fuck. And she told me that. And I love that. I couldn't stop.
他们太难相处了。她爸爸对她说，道，如果你没有一个能教你的人，你将如何学会耐心？是的。我当时就想，该死。她告诉了我这些。我喜欢这个。我无法停止。
I was like, thank you, Dawah. And I went to the other room and just immediately started crying. Yeah. Also, you have to meet some of, you have to meet people where they are, right? So like, like if someone's a type A and you're not, but you just have to kind of meet them halfway, right? So about the last, you guys know, and you guys have been on this thing with me, again, we don't want, it's not like now for a very heavy, very special, very smart less this
我当时想，谢谢你，道。我走到另一个房间，立刻开始哭泣。是的。另外，你必须在人们所在的地方遇见他们，对吧？所以，如果有人是A型人格，而你不是，但你只需要在某种程度上与他们相遇，对吧？所以关于最后，你们知道，你们一直和我一起经历这件事，再说一次，我们不想，这不像现在为了一个非常沉重、非常特别、非常SmartLess的
Thursday, smart less on a very, but I, I've been going through a lot of stuff and I was in Atlanta and I was thinking a lot of this stuff really kind of came to the surface and I was thinking about all this stuff and I listened to a record that really touched me, kind of talked about meet you where you are, really hit me where I was. Is it the soundtrack to Willy Wonka? It was, yeah. Have you heard it? Yeah.
周四，SmartLess在一个非常，但我，我经历了很多事情，我在亚特兰大，我一直在想很多这些事情真的浮出水面了，我一直在想所有这些事情，我听了一张真正触动我的唱片，谈到了在你的位置遇见你，真的击中了我的心。是《威利·旺卡》的原声带吗？是的，是。你听过吗？是的。
I love that you were spinning vinyl down in Atlanta. I wish it was vinyl, but I was, I was sent this record and I started listening to it from the first track all the way through, like you listened, we used to listen to albums in that way and that's what I did with this record and I had, and I listened to this and every step of the way, every song was hitting me in this place and I don't know if it's because where I was at and, but it really spoke to me in this way that I've never experienced before in the first time listened to a record or song, song by song, I was like, holy shit. At one point I thought I was going to have to pull over because I was so emotional.
我喜欢你在亚特兰大转黑胶唱片的样子。我希望那是黑胶唱片，但我，我收到了这张唱片，我开始从第一首曲目一直听到最后，就像你听的那样，我们过去常那样听专辑，这就是我对这张唱片所做的，我当时，我听了这个，每一步，每一首歌都在击中我的那个地方，我不知道是不是因为我当时所处的位置，而且，但它真的以一种我从未经历过的方式对我说话，第一次听一张唱片或一首歌，一首接一首，我当时想，天哪。有一次我以为我不得不靠边停车，因为我太激动了。
It's making me emotional thinking about it. And I ended up reaching out to the people in this band because I was like, I have to talk to them and let them know what an impact it's had. And this is a band that I've really admired and listened to since the day, from the moment I first heard one note of their music, I was completely engrossed with what they were doing. This is a band that has a lot of members in it and has had various people from time to time. But at the core are two people who, I think who met at a time in their life where they
想到它让我很激动。我最终联系了这个乐队的人，因为我当时想，我必须和他们谈谈，让他们知道它产生了多大的影响。这是一个我从听到他们音乐的第一音符起就非常钦佩和聆听的乐队，我完全沉浸在他们所做的事情中。这是一个有很多成员的乐队，不时有不同的人加入。但核心是两个人，我认为他们在生命中相遇的时候，他们
just, it seems to me and we'll find out that they just creatively, they came together and they, it's like this combustion, like this thing happened and they just started creating incredible stuff. Simon. They're Canadian, partially Canadian, mostly Canadian, but. Is this Ace of Bays? They are incredible writers, incredible songwriters, they're poets, I guess they're philosophers. And they're rockers and they hit me in a way that also is, like strikes every indie rock
只是，在我看来，我们会发现他们只是在创造力上，他们走到了一起，他们，就像这种燃烧，就像发生了这件事，他们就开始创造不可思议的东西。西蒙。他们是加拿大人，部分是加拿大人，主要是加拿大人，但是。这是Ace of Bays吗？他们是不可思议的作家，不可思议的词曲作者，他们是诗人，我想他们是哲学家。他们是摇滚乐手，他们以一种也像击中我身体里每一根独立摇滚骨头的方式击中了我
bone in my body and I hate even putting that classification, just music bone in my body. They're the incredible. They represent one of the greatest bands today. Keep it together. Butler and Regine Chassain of Simon and Garfunkel. There they are. God. Yeah.
我甚至讨厌给它贴上那个分类，只是我身体里的音乐骨头。他们是不可思议的。他们代表了当今最伟大的乐队之一。坚持住。巴特勒和雷吉娜·沙森，西蒙和加芬克尔。他们就在那里。上帝。是的。
Oh my gosh. Hello guys. Yeah. Wow. Hi there. Garfunkel. Art, you look amazing. This day has been.
天哪。你们好。是的。哇。你们好。加芬克尔。阿特，你看起来棒极了。这一天已经。
Art looks amazing. I didn't like, seriously, art. Wait, wait a minute. That new wig art is just stunning. I have to tell you, Will, I have to tell you, of course I know who you are. I, Will's like, you've got to buy this album. I bought the album, like, what is that? iTunes?
阿特看起来棒极了。我不喜欢，说真的，阿特。等等，等等。那个新假发阿特简直太惊艳了。我必须告诉你，威尔，我必须告诉你，我当然知道你是谁。我，威尔就像，你必须买这张专辑。我买了这张专辑，就像，那是什么？iTunes？
Yeah, exactly. It's not a buy. You bought it? I did the same thing. Yeah, I bought it. So cute. That's adorable. But you can't buy them, right?
是的，没错。这不是买。你买了？我也做了同样的事。是的，我买了。太可爱了。那太可爱了。但你不能买它们，对吧？
I didn't know people did that still. That's amazing. Well, how would I get it? I don't know. Because if you just have like Apple Music subscription. I don't. I have to buy it. Okay.
我不知道人们还在那样做。那太棒了。嗯，我怎么得到它？我不知道。因为如果你只是有像Apple Music订阅。我没有。我必须买它。好的。
Hang on. Okay. Hang on. Go into settings. No, right. But isn't that the way it is now? So, you can add to your library. Yes, but it was done.
等等。好的。等等。进入设置。不，对。但现在不是这样了吗？所以，你可以添加到你的库中。是的，但它完成了。
Yeah. I didn't get charged anything. I know it's all the music of all recorded history for like $10 a month. It's ridiculous. Oh, really? Is that why? Is that real? It's awesome.
是的。我没有被收取任何费用。我知道这是所有录制历史的音乐，每月大约10美元。这太荒谬了。哦，真的吗？这就是原因吗？那是真的吗？这太棒了。
And that's why touring, touring is so huge now, right? Because it's the only way that bands can monetize their music anymore, correct? Aside from the piece you get from the subscription services. Yeah. You don't really get paid for streaming unless you're Drake. Right. He gets, they pay him. Oh, really?
这就是为什么巡演，巡演现在如此巨大，对吧？因为这是乐队现在唯一能从音乐中获利的方式，对吗？除了你从订阅服务中获得的部分。是的。除非你是德雷克，否则你真的不会因为流媒体而得到报酬。对。他们付钱给他。哦，真的吗？
They worked out to change your band name. All the money just, yeah, we tried and the lawsuit was, it's merchandise and touring. Right? Mostly touring. Yeah. So, when in regime, I'm not allowed to tell these guys, we never tell each other who our guests are. Yeah.
他们想出了改变你的乐队名字。所有的钱只是，是的，我们尝试了，诉讼是，它是商品和巡演。对吧？主要是巡演。是的。所以，当在雷吉娜，我不被允许告诉这些家伙，我们从不告诉对方我们的嘉宾是谁。是的。
But I needed them a few weeks ago. I needed them to listen to your music. Luckily you guys got COVID. Yeah. Because you were supposed to be on this show. I'm sorry. I say luckily for us. Just me.
但我几周前需要他们。我需要他们听你们的音乐。幸运的是你们得了新冠。是的。因为你们本应该在这个节目上。我很抱歉。我说对我们来说很幸运。只是我。
Yeah. Or just you win. Yeah. And then you guys, and so these guys had a chance to, and I said, somewhere down the road, this is going to come in handy, please listen to this record because I hope it touches you the way that it touched me. Yeah. Only Stacey Abrams and Kamala Harris were the other two that we were given a heads up
是的。或者只是你赢了。是的。然后你们，所以这些家伙有机会，我说，在未来的某个时候，这会派上用场，请听这张唱片，因为我希望它能像触动我一样触动你们。是的。只有斯泰西·艾布拉姆斯和卡玛拉·哈里斯是我们被告知的另外两个
that were coming on the show. Her record's amazing, by the way, is her voice, it's melodic, it'll pick up on you. And then Stacey Abrams, this is true story, actually writes romance novels. Yeah. No, but did you know that? Stacey Abrams writes romance novels. That's cool. She does.
要上节目的。顺便说一句，她的唱片很棒，是她的声音，它是旋律优美的，它会吸引你。然后斯泰西·艾布拉姆斯，这是一个真实的故事，实际上写浪漫小说。是的。不，但你知道吗？斯泰西·艾布拉姆斯写浪漫小说。那很酷。她确实写。
On the side. It's actually very prolific. Yeah. Now, sorry, just so I can be clear. Regine, I'm saying your name correct, Regine Chassain. Oh yeah, Chassain. Chassain. Yeah.
在业余时间。实际上非常多产。是的。现在，抱歉，为了让我清楚。雷吉娜，我发你的名字正确吗，雷吉娜·沙森。哦，是的，沙森。沙森。是的。
Oh, look at you guys. Well, she's already correct and my friends are terrible. I know. It was pretty good. How do you pronounce your first name? Regine. Regine. Regine.
哦，看看你们。嗯，她已经正确了，我的朋友们很糟糕。我知道。这相当不错。你的名字怎么发音？雷吉娜。雷吉娜。雷吉娜。
Regine. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Regine. Now, listen. You try. This isn't weird at all.
雷吉娜。是的。是的。好的。雷吉娜。现在，听着。你试试。这根本不奇怪。
This is super normal. Everyone together. Regine. Regine. Regine. Regine. Regine. Well, Regine.
这超级正常。大家一起。雷吉娜。雷吉娜。雷吉娜。雷吉娜。雷吉娜。嗯，雷吉娜。
Oh, it's not French. Yes, of course. We can speak French a little bit. No way. Okay. We can interview you in French. Well, yes. We can do it in French or in Quebec.
哦，这不是法语。是的，当然。我们可以说一点法语。不会吧。好的。我们可以用法语采访你。嗯，是的。我们可以用法语或魁北克语做。
Yes. Choisi. Choisi, yes. In Quebec. Yes. I parked my car. My car. By the way, so guys, first of all, after 10 minutes of pronouncing Regine's name.
是的。Choisi。Choisi，是的。在魁北克。是的。我停了我的车。我的车。顺便说一句，所以伙计们，首先，在发了10分钟雷吉娜的名字之后。
Regine. Regine. I'm so excited you guys are here. Talk to me a little bit about, was I right. You guys came together at a time in your lives. Regine, you were already in Montreal. And when you were going to McGill. Is that right?
雷吉娜。雷吉娜。我很高兴你们在这里。跟我谈谈，我是对的吗。你们在生命中的某个时刻走到了一起。雷吉娜，你已经在蒙特利尔了。当你去麦吉尔的时候。那是对的吗？
That's sort of the move. Dude, of course. I dropped out of Concordia in Montreal. Yeah. I went to Concordia. We both went to Concordia. Did you guys drop out too? I transferred.
那算是那种举动。伙计，当然。我从蒙特利尔的康考迪亚大学退学了。是的。我去了康考迪亚。我们都去了康考迪亚。你们也退学了吗？我转学了。
I dropped out of McGill. Regine dropped out of McGill. I did one better, dropped out of high school. That's cool. What grade? Ninth, right? Just two weeks short of finishing 12th. Yeah, I've...
我从麦吉尔退学了。雷吉娜从麦吉尔退学了。我做得更好，从高中退学了。那很酷。几年级？九年级，对吧？离完成十二年级只差两周。是的，我……
Did you ever go back, GED? I went back, I talked to the headmaster, tried to get a diploma out of him and he asked me for a donation to the school instead. It was a shakedown. Did they do honorary degrees for high school? Oh, that's... That's what I was lobbying for,
你回去过吗，GED？我回去过，我和校长谈过，试图从他那里拿到文凭，但他反而向我索要学校捐款。那是一次敲诈。他们有高中的荣誉学位吗？哦，那是……那就是我一直在游说的，
a doctorate for high school. That would be great. That would be great. I want it. Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. Now, where are you guys in your musical life right now? Are you in the studio recording or are you touring? This is nothing.
高中的博士学位。那会很棒。那会很棒。我想要它。哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。现在，你们现在的音乐生活处于什么阶段？你们是在录音室录音还是在巡演？这没什么。
Neither. Excellent. You're golfing. No, no, no, no. The record just came out and we're going on tour in the fall but we're actually kind of not working, which is... Nice. For the summer.
都不是。太棒了。你们在打高尔夫球。不，不，不，不。唱片刚出来，我们秋天要巡演，但我们实际上有点没在工作，这是……不错。为了夏天。
It's really strange. Are you guys a couple or just a parts of the band together? We're a couple, yeah. Okay, nice. Couple of goofy kids who are just making music. Couple of crazy kids who love music. That's cute. Yeah, and you guys have a son.
这真的很奇怪。你们是一对情侣还是只是乐队的一部分？我们是一对，是的。好的，不错。一对傻乎乎的孩子，只是在做音乐。一对热爱音乐的疯狂孩子。那很可爱。是的，你们有一个儿子。
How old is your son? He's nine. He's nine. He had his favorite part of Lego Batman is the nine-pack joke. No one. And he was like, tell him about the... I was like, do you have any messages? He's like, the nine-pack, that's really funny.
你们儿子多大了？他九岁。他九岁。他最喜欢《乐高蝙蝠侠》的部分是九块腹肌的笑话。没有人。他当时说，告诉他关于……我当时说，你有什么信息吗？他说，九块腹肌，那真的很有趣。
Walk us through that, Willie. I remember, because these kids watch so many Marvel movies and he was like, Dad, why doesn't your stomach look like the people in the movies? And I was like, well, son. You have to be a cartoon. Sean's been getting in shape for a Marvel movie. Show him, Sean.
带我们过一遍，威利。我记得，因为这些孩子看了太多漫威电影，他当时说，爸爸，为什么你的肚子看起来不像电影里的人？我当时说，嗯，儿子。你必须是一个卡通人物。肖恩一直在为漫威电影锻炼身体。给他看看，肖恩。
Let's see. It's incredible. Who likes cookies? Who likes it? How do you do that? What's the secret? Well, you start with some ice cream. Yeah.
让我们看看。这太不可思议了。谁喜欢饼干？谁喜欢它？你是怎么做到的？秘诀是什么？嗯，你从一些冰淇淋开始。是的。
Jason calls it my cookie pouch. Although, you know, we always say there's nothing less funny than a six-pack. Yeah. You know what I mean? It used to be a mark of wealth back in the old days, right? The King Arthur days. Like, that was, you didn't look like you were in charge
杰森称它为我的饼干袋。虽然，你知道，我们总是说没有什么比六块腹肌更不有趣的了。是的。你知道我的意思吗？过去在旧时代，它是财富的标志，对吧？亚瑟王时代。就像，那是，你看起来不像是在负责
or powerful or wealthy unless you were big and fat. Oh my God, you didn't go to high school. Big and fat. You know, I was working out a lot during Will and Grace and Jimmy Burroughs, the director said, you got to stop because big isn't funny. It's true. I've always lived by that creed.
或者强大或富有，除非你又大又胖。哦，天哪，你没上过高中。又大又胖。你知道，我在《威尔和格蕾丝》期间锻炼了很多，导演吉米·伯罗斯说，你必须停止，因为大并不好笑。这是真的。我一直遵循那个信条。
Yeah. Yeah. Unless it's big around the waist. Yeah. Wait, so you guys, various colleges and transferring and quitting and whatever, but when you find your way to Montreal... Yeah, I think it's Montreal.
是的。是的。除非它在腰部周围很大。是的。等等，所以你们，各种大学和转学和退学等等，但当你找到去蒙特利尔的路时……是的，我想是蒙特利尔。
Yeah, Montreal. Montreal. And wait, is this... And so you find your way to Montreal and then what? How does it come together that you start making music with all these Canadians? Well, I... Then you start going, a one and a two.
是的，蒙特利尔。蒙特利尔。等等，这是……所以你找到了去蒙特利尔的路，然后呢？你们是怎么走到一起开始和所有这些加拿大人一起做音乐的？嗯，我……然后你开始，一和二。
Yeah, usually someone counts it in. Yeah, and then you just start making music. There's a lot of writing. I dropped out of art school and started a band as one does and my bandmate had gone to Concordia in Montreal because it was so cheap. It was like half price for American, you know, I think their exchange rate was like half then
是的，通常有人会数拍子。是的，然后你就开始做音乐了。有很多写作。我从艺术学校退学并组建了一个乐队，就像人们所做的那样，我的乐队成员去了蒙特利尔的康考迪亚大学，因为它太便宜了。对美国人来说大约是半价，你知道，我想他们的汇率当时大约是一半
and it was also like $3,000 a year to go to college, which is pretty amazing. So he was going back to school there and I sort of followed him. I didn't know anything about Montreal or Quebec or anything, but I got there and it was sort of like... What I thought New York was going to be like, it was like kind of the same...
而且上大学一年只要3000美元，这相当惊人。所以他回到那里上学，我算是跟着他。我对蒙特利尔或魁北克一无所知，但我到了那里，它有点像……我以为纽约会是什么样子，它有点像……
It's kind of the same soup as Brooklyn or something. It's like tons of African, North African, French Caribbean and like... But it was also cheap and there was crazy art. Every, you know, like contemporary dance and cool electronic music and everything was at an illegal loft and it was like shit was just happening
它有点像布鲁克林之类的汤。它有大量的非洲人、北非人、法属加勒比人，而且像……但它也很便宜，而且有疯狂的艺术。每一个，你知道，像现代舞和酷的电子音乐，一切都在一个非法的阁楼里，就像事情正在发生
in a really cool way. For Jason and Sean, I don't know if you guys have ever been in Montreal. It's such an incredibly vibrant city in a way. It's like this jewel of North America that doesn't... It's kind of good that it doesn't get talked about because it doesn't get overrun. I've got a half brother there.
以一种非常酷的方式。对于杰森和肖恩，我不知道你们是否去过蒙特利尔。它是一个如此充满活力的城市。它就像北美这颗宝石，不……它不被谈论其实挺好的，因为它不会被挤爆。我在那里有一个同父异母的兄弟。
Hello, Derek. Oh, you do? And sorry, where did you come from before you got to Montreal? I was born in Northern California. But my dad's from Maine and my mom's from LA. So I have like in New England, I've got a bunch of Maine people.
你好，德里克。哦，你有吗？抱歉，你在去蒙特利尔之前是从哪里来的？我出生在北加州。但我爸爸来自缅因州，我妈妈来自洛杉矶。所以我像在新英格兰，我有一群缅因州的人。
So I ended up going to boarding school and for the end of high school in New Hampshire. So did Will. Yeah, not in New Hampshire. Where did you do? North of Toronto. I don't want to give them any credit because you know what I mean?
所以我最终去了寄宿学校，并在新罕布什尔州完成了高中。威尔也是。是的，不是在新罕布什尔。你在哪里做的？多伦多以北。我不想给他们任何功劳，因为你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, fuck them honestly. They claim kick out. I said they asked me not to come back. Honorary degree. Anyway, so you go, so you're from Maine and Northern California, but you find your way to Montreal and then Jean, you're from Montreal.
是的，说实话去他们的。他们声称踢出去。我说他们要求我不要回来。荣誉学位。总之，所以你去，所以你来自缅因州和北加州，但你找到了去蒙特利尔的路，然后让，你来自蒙特利尔。
You're of Haitian descent. Your parents are Haitian immigrants. Yes. Move to Montreal. And... From Haiti, you moved to Montreal? Were you born in Montreal or Haiti? I was born in Montreal.
你是海地裔。你的父母是海地移民。是的。搬到蒙特利尔。而且……从海地，你搬到了蒙特利尔？你是出生在蒙特利尔还是海地？我出生在蒙特利尔。
Okay. And you started making music in your head when you were really young. Is that right? That's what I read once. Regina is by far the most accomplished musical member. I mean, she's just like one of those savant types who taught herself classical music
好的。你很小的时候就开始在脑子里做音乐了。那是对的吗？我曾经读到过。雷吉娜是迄今为止最有成就的音乐成员。我的意思是，她就像那种自学成才的学者类型
in the basement when she was five. Wow. And she, like on our first record, the first song, Tunnels, like she started playing drums like a week before we cut that. It's like... No way.
五岁时在地下室里。哇。而且她，就像在我们的第一张唱片上，第一首歌，《隧道》，就像我们在剪辑那首歌前一周她开始打鼓。就像……不会吧。
Because we didn't have a drummer at the time. She's like, I can play drums like you can. It's like, well, I'd never done it, but let me just figure it out really quick. I'm just like, insane, just insane. And like, yeah. So she's like that type. I love that.
因为我们当时没有鼓手。她说，我可以像你一样打鼓。就像，嗯，我从来没做过，但我让我很快弄清楚。我只是觉得，疯狂，简直疯狂。而且，是的。所以她是那种类型。我喜欢那个。
Wow. That is so... And Haji, were you making music? I also read once that you were like making music in like shopping centers, and that's how you guys met. Is that a true story? Or am I mixing it up?
哇。那太……还有哈吉，你在做音乐吗？我还读到过你曾经在购物中心之类的做音乐，这就是你们相遇的方式。这是一个真实的故事吗？还是我记混了？
That's kind of a mix up, but I did do a million gigs, million different jobs, too many to remember. I was with a person driving around in Montreal one time and for like a month and she says, you know, Regina, every time we go somewhere, you say, oh, I used to work here. Oh, I used to work there.
那有点混淆了，但我确实做了一百万场演出，一百万种不同的工作，多到记不住。有一次我和一个人在蒙特利尔开车，大约一个月，她说，你知道，雷吉娜，每次我们去某个地方，你就说，哦，我以前在这里工作。哦，我以前在那里工作。
Oh, I worked here. Oh yeah, I worked there, too. I was like, wait, you worked everywhere. Now, were you quitting a lot or getting fired a lot? The stuff that I would quit was like telemarketing and things that where I could be replaced very easily. Yeah. Have you ever fired for anything?
哦，我在这里工作。哦，是的，我也在那里工作。我当时想，等等，你到处都工作过。现在，你是经常辞职还是经常被解雇？我辞职的东西就像电话推销和那些我可以很容易被取代的事情。是的。你曾经因为什么被解雇吗？
No, yeah. Yeah, I don't quit on people. I just quit on things where I knew that it wouldn't matter. I love that. I don't quit on people. I just quit on people. I love that. Regine, I like when it just rolled off my tongue.
不，是的。是的，我不辞掉人。我只是辞掉那些我知道无关紧要的事情。我喜欢那个。我不辞掉人。我只是辞掉人。我喜欢那个。雷吉娜，我喜欢它从我舌尖滑落的感觉。
Regine, it was my dream, my whole life to play the piano at malls. I thought you made it if you played at Nordstrom or like some kind of department store. And so my whole life I'd be like, if I can just get a job, how great would that be? I'd just go to the mall. I play, I get a check, I go home.
雷吉娜，我一生的梦想就是在商场里弹钢琴。我以为如果你在诺德斯特龙或某种百货公司演奏，你就成功了。所以我一生都在想，如果我能找到一份工作，那该多好啊？我只是去商场。我演奏，我拿到支票，我回家。
I thought you had it made. Anyways, I ended up working. Once you get to work out the mall. I did that stuff. I was dressed like an elf and I played in a hallmarks. And I also was dressed with a wedding dress that I got at the thrift store. You worked in the fish department.
我以为你成功了。总之，我最终工作了。一旦你在商场工作。我做了那些事。我打扮成精灵，我在霍尔马克演奏。我还穿着我在旧货店买的婚纱。你在鱼类部门工作。
Yeah, I sang jazz. Bossa Nova in the fish department of the grocery store opening. We got that sea bass. We got that fresh. You know the ice, the ice scraping sort of when they move the ice around. Yeah. It's hysterical.
是的，我在杂货店开业的鱼类部门唱爵士乐。波萨诺瓦。我们有那个海鲈鱼。我们有那个新鲜的。你知道冰，冰刮那种当他们移动冰的时候。是的。这太歇斯底里了。
Fresh sea bass. Go ahead, Sean. Come on, Regine. I played an elf on the Kenny Rogers Christmas tour. Ooh. How good is that? That's the end of the story. And it was, she was not playing a piano.
新鲜海鲈鱼。继续，肖恩。来吧，雷吉娜。我在肯尼·罗杰斯圣诞巡演中扮演了一个精灵。哦。那有多好？那是故事的结尾。而且它，她没有在弹钢琴。
It was a, it was a keytar, right Sean? As a kid. As a kid. Yeah, I was playing a keytar. Sean, you always had that elf bar then. Yeah. Yeah. It goes, it goes that far.
那是一个，那是一个肩背式键盘，对吧肖恩？作为一个孩子。作为一个孩子。是的，我在弹肩背式键盘。肖恩，你那时就有那个精灵酒吧了。是的。是的。它走得那么远。
It's coming after you now, Sean. Go get him. They brought all the boys to the yard. Sean played, Sean has possibly trained pianist. And he went to, he was a music, he was a piano major in college. Yes. And he's very musical.
它现在要来找你了，肖恩。去抓住他。他们把所有的男孩都带到了院子里。肖恩弹，肖恩可能是训练有素的钢琴家。他去了，他是大学的钢琴专业。是的。而且他非常有音乐天赋。
We keep telling him he needs to have a keyboard while we do the show to just kind of, you know, take us and he won't do it. I don't know why. I know, I guess I got to move all this equipment over to the thing, but next time. What do you call the equipment? You're in, you've got a bookshelf behind you.
我们一直告诉他，当我们在做节目时，他需要有一个键盘来，你知道，带我们，但他不会做。我不知道为什么。我知道，我想我得把所有这些设备搬到那个东西上，但下次吧。你把设备叫什么？你，你后面有一个书架。
Casio keyboard. Could be the fucking Paul Schaefer podcast thing. Yes, yes. You know what? I'm going to start doing that well. I'm going to start, I got to move, I'm going to move all this stuff and I'll live in the room next time.
卡西欧键盘。可能是该死的保罗·谢弗播客之类的东西。是的，是的。你知道吗？我开始那样做，威尔。我开始，我得搬，我得搬所有这些东西，下次我住在房间里。
By the way, you're not moving anything. Your husband, Scotty, does everything. So you don't even do it. Why would you do that? Because we could have had like some like back and forth because you know there's a piano right there. I know that would have been great. And we will be right back and now back to the show.
顺便说一句，你什么都没搬。你丈夫，斯科蒂，做了一切。所以你甚至没做。你为什么要那样做？因为我们本可以有一些像来回的，因为你知道那里有一架钢琴。我知道那会很棒。我们马上回来，现在回到节目。
Now, what about your son? Is your nine year old musically inclined at all? Yes. Yeah. It's kind of scary, scary. Oh really? Yeah. He's got a little bit.
现在，你的儿子怎么样？你九岁的孩子有音乐天赋吗？是的。是的。这有点吓人，吓人。哦，真的吗？是的。他有一点。
He came out gifted. I don't know. He just, he's just around it so much. He lives in the studio with us basically. And what would his specialty be at this point? If you had to make a guess where he's going to really excel, is it going to be on a particular instrument or singing or writing?
他生来就有天赋。我不知道。他只是，他只是经常在它周围。他基本上和我们住在录音室里。如果现在要猜测他会在哪里真正出色，他的专长会是什么？是某种特定的乐器还是唱歌或写作？
Well, he lives in New Orleans. So he's around like the people are playing drums in the street all the time. Like he's just, you know. I'd love if you were like, we live in Montreal, but he lives in New Orleans. He's moved out. He's got his own apartment.
嗯，他住在新奥尔良。所以他周围就像人们一直在街上打鼓。就像他只是，你知道。如果你们说，我们住在蒙特利尔，但他住在新奥尔良，我会很高兴。他搬出去了。他有自己的公寓。
He likes to drink. Living in Montreal was really like messy enough his drinking schedule. Are we not in Montreal right now? No. No, we're in New Orleans. Oh, God. Okay, so you guys met, started in Montreal.
他喜欢喝酒。住在蒙特利尔真的足以让他的饮酒时间表混乱。我们现在不在蒙特利尔吗？不。不，我们在新奥尔良。哦，上帝。好的，所以你们相遇，在蒙特利尔开始。
The band started there. Yeah. You have now journeyed down to New Orleans. That's where bass is. Yeah, but we're kind of back and forth. We sort of do the opposite Canadian thing where we go north in the summertime. Do you take the kid with you when you go north?
乐队在那里开始。是的。你们现在已经旅程到了新奥尔良。那是贝斯所在的地方。是的，但我们有点来回。我们有点做相反的加拿大事情，我们在夏天去北方。你们去北方时带孩子吗？
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Of course. Well, listen, the guy likes to drink. He's got probably a favorite bar. He doesn't want to be away from that. They're not on Ozark and like leaving their kids for five years, like some assholes.
是的。是的，是的。当然。嗯，听着，那家伙喜欢喝酒。他可能有一个最喜欢的酒吧。他不想离开那个。他们不像某些混蛋那样在奥扎克，像五年不理他们的孩子。
You know what I mean? Listen, the price is right. I love hearing Americans say Montreal too. It's always so amazing. Montreal. Well, it's spelt with an O, not a U, so. It must be hard if you're directing an episode of something to have your kid there.
你知道我的意思吗？听着，价格是正确的。我也喜欢听美国人说蒙特利尔。这总是太神奇了。蒙特利尔。嗯，它是用O拼写的，不是U，所以。如果你在导演某件事的一集，让你的孩子在那里一定很难。
Like, dad, hey dad, dad, dad. No, exactly. Dad, what are you doing, dad? Why are you killing that person? What did that person do to you? Although you, Jason, you did, you've had the girls there before when you were directing episodes, did you have?
就像，爸爸，嘿爸爸，爸爸，爸爸。不，完全正确。爸爸，你在做什么，爸爸？你为什么要杀那个人？那个人对你做了什么？虽然你，杰森，你确实，你在导演剧集时以前让女孩们在那里，你有吗？
Yeah. You had Maple there when you were directing, right? Yeah, but they could not care less. It's all about what's at the craft service table. It's all about snacks. Snacks can hold their attention if they're happy. Otherwise. You don't have to pay for the snacks even in Hollywood.
是的。你在导演时让枫树在那里，对吧？是的，但他们根本不在乎。一切都是关于餐车桌上有什么。一切都是关于零食。如果他们开心，零食可以吸引他们的注意力。否则。即使在好莱坞，你也不必为零食付费。
Snacks are free. Snacks are free. Well, you're paying for it, don't worry. But I always say, the joke I always say to my kids when they come to work is like, when they come in and they're getting ready, I'm like, you guys love watching your dad get his makeup put on in that voice.
零食是免费的。零食是免费的。嗯，你在为它付费，别担心。但我总是说，我总是对我的孩子们说的笑话是，当他们来工作时，就像，当他们进来并准备好时，我就像，你们喜欢看你们的爸爸用那种声音化妆。
You know, we talk about this a lot though, when it's like, you know, I'm always fascinated. If I was, because I knew as a kid, I loved the arts and theater and acting and movies and all those kinds of things. I knew from a very young age. And I was always like, I'm always blown away. Like Jason, you just said Maple,
你知道，我们经常谈论这个，当它就像，你知道，我总是很着迷。如果我是，因为我知道作为一个孩子，我喜欢艺术、戏剧、表演和电影以及所有这些东西。我从小就知道。我总是，我总是被震撼。就像杰森，你刚才说枫树，
just like she couldn't care less. Like when she gets older, is she gonna be as Maple or your son when, is he gonna be like, shit, I wish I would have tuned in a little bit sooner. Cause that's really cool. They'll appreciate it later. I doubt it.
就像她根本不在乎。就像当她长大后，她会像枫树或你的儿子一样，当他长大后，他会像，该死，我希望我能早点调入。因为那真的很酷。他们以后会欣赏它的。我怀疑。
I doubt it. Yeah, it'll be, no, they don't care. They don't care. Well, they do care. These are, it's hard. How can they possibly put it in context at this age? They can't. Did you care what your parents were doing
我怀疑。是的，它会是，不，他们不在乎。他们不在乎。嗯，他们确实在乎。这些是，这很难。他们怎么可能在这个年龄把事情放在背景中？他们不能。你关心你的父母在做什么吗
you were growing up? Imagine hanging out with my, I'm trying to imagine hanging out with my dad at his office, his office like all the time. He's like, dad, dad, is your son impressed with what you guys do? Does he, does he get what you guys are doing? He totally gets it.
你长大的时候？想象一下和我，我试着想象一直和我爸爸在他的办公室，他的办公室里闲逛。他就像，爸爸，爸爸，你儿子对你们做的事情印象深刻吗？他，他明白你们在做什么吗？他完全明白。
Yeah. And is he impressed? Does he give it up? Does he, does he? It's kind of his too. You know, it's like, yeah. Yeah. He helps out?
是的。而且他印象深刻吗？他放弃了吗？他，他吗？这也有点是他的。你知道，就像，是的。是的。他帮忙吗？
Luckily we're good. It'd be really awkward if we sucked. And he was like, dad, oh my God. I want to be just like them. No. If he was like, I have to like my parents and it's terrible, would be messed up. But he, what kind of music, other than arcade fire,
幸运的是我们很好。如果我们很烂，那会很尴尬。他就像，爸爸，哦，天哪。我想变得和他们一模一样。不。如果他就像，我必须像我的父母，而且这很糟糕，那会搞砸的。但他，除了拱廊之火，
what kind of music do you think he would listen to? If you were like, hey, put something on the record player. What would he? Beast, Beastie Boys. He really knows. No, no. He really understands music that's like really genuine and original versus stuff
你认为他会听什么样的音乐？如果你就像，嘿，在唱片机上放点东西。他会？野兽，野兽男孩。他真的知道。不，不。他真的理解像真正真实和原创的音乐，而不是那些
that's just like crap, you know, crapped out to go on the radio. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he'll listen to something and he'll know that this comes from here and this comes from this band and this, this sounds like. Yeah, he knows Jamaican music. He knows Haitian music. He knows jazz.
只是像垃圾，你知道，为了上电台而拉出来的东西。是的，是的，是的。他会听一些东西，他会知道这来自这里，这来自这个乐队，这，这听起来像。是的，他知道牙买加音乐。他知道海地音乐。他知道爵士乐。
He knows classical. He knows, he knows. Yeah, wow. But I think about that sometimes too, because it's like I, there's the stuff that you're exposed to when you're a kid that's like not at all of your generation. Like I, I was obsessed with like 50s music when I was,
他知道古典音乐。他知道，他知道。是的，哇。但我有时也会想到这一点，因为就像我，有些东西是你小时候接触到的，根本不是你那一代的。就像我，我痴迷于像50年代的音乐，当我，
because I heard Stand By Me when I was a little kid. I remember the first time I heard Stand By Me and I was just like what, like it just, because it conjures it so emotionally deep and the soundscape of it, like the first second I heard it, like the lyrics are about the mountains crumbling to the sea and I would imagine, like, you know, like your imagination is so fresh when you're then.
因为我小时候听过《伴我同行》。我记得我第一次听到《伴我同行》的时候，我当时就想什么，就像它，因为它在情感上如此深刻地唤起了它，它的音景，就像我听到的第一秒，就像歌词是关于山脉崩塌到海里，我会想象，就像，你知道，就像你的想象力在那个时候是如此新鲜。
I would imagine the mountains crumbling and it just was this epic, you know, like, like, like almost like visual landscape. And then, so I just was really imprinted with this stuff that was not, you know, I was in suburban Houston in like the 80s and like listening to this music from the 50s and they really liked stirring my soul. The 50s music is like one, four, five chords,
我会想象山脉崩塌，它只是这个史诗般的，你知道，就像，就像，几乎就像视觉景观。然后，所以我只是被这些东西深深打动了，不是，你知道，我在80年代的休斯顿郊区，就像听着50年代的音乐，它们真的喜欢触动我的灵魂。50年代的音乐就像一、四、五和弦，
every single song. Every song, yeah. Louis Louis, the opening of Louis Louis, the easiest way to, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, every song is those three chords over and over five minutes. I could have written that. But it ain't what you do, it's the way that you do it. Exactly.
每一首歌。每一首歌，是的。路易路易，路易路易的开头，最简单的方法，蹦，蹦，蹦，蹦，蹦，每一首歌都是那三个和弦一遍又一遍五分钟。我本可以写那个。但这不是你做什么，而是你做它的方式。完全正确。
Eugene, what kind of music, so with your background, what kind of music were you listening to when you were like, you guys were teenagers growing up in separate places, you were in Montreal, what were you listening to? What was informing or feeding your musical appetite? What did I listen to? It's very...
尤金，什么样的音乐，所以以你的背景，当你像，你们是青少年在不同的地方长大，你在蒙特利尔，你在听什么样的音乐？什么在通知或喂养你的音乐胃口？我听了什么？这非常……
Rochoisine? Rochoisine, I mean, Rochoisine was on the radio, of course, you can really escape it. I listened to classical music, Billie Hall, the first tape, the first cassette I bought, I had to like, I didn't have a lot of money to buy, I didn't have like a collection of records, I only had my grandma's records.
罗乔辛？罗乔辛，我的意思是，罗乔辛当然在电台上，你真的可以逃避它。我听古典音乐，比莉·霍尔，第一盘磁带，我买的第一盘磁带，我不得不像，我没有很多钱买，我没有像唱片收藏，我只有我奶奶的唱片。
And then when I had money, I was like, okay, I'm gonna go buy something and I have to buy something quality because it has to last forever and I just, so I bought a double tape, double cassette, of Billie Holiday, I was like, can't go wrong with this, can't go, it's just a double cassette of Billie Holiday,
然后当我有了钱，我当时想，好的，我要去买点东西，我必须买点质量好的东西，因为它必须永远持续下去，我只是，所以我买了一盘双磁带，双盒式磁带，比莉·霍尔的，我当时想，买这个不会错，不会，它只是比莉·霍尔的双盒式磁带，
I will always love this. And then the second cassette I got was Bob Marley and then Legend and then, but besides that, I listened to my grandmother's records and... What was the classical music that you loved the most? Well, when I was really young, the first piece I ever heard was Mozart's Symphony No. 40, I think. The Jupiter.
我永远会喜欢这个。然后我得到的第二盘磁带是鲍勃·马利和然后传奇，然后，但除此之外，我听了我奶奶的唱片和……你最喜欢的古典音乐是什么？嗯，当我真的很小的时候，我听到的第一首曲子是莫扎特的第40交响曲，我想。朱庇特。
The Jupiter? It's called the Jupiter Symphony, yeah. How does it go, Sean? Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. That's a, that's the overture to marriage a figaro. No, that is not. Oh, no, that's sorry, that's the Rondo Allaterca, that's an A minor. Yes.
朱庇特？是叫朱庇特交响曲，没错。肖恩，它是怎么唱的？哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。那是，《费加罗的婚礼》序曲。不，那不是。哦，不，抱歉，那是《回旋曲》，是A小调的。是的。
Oh, thank you so much for... Fight, fight, fight, fight. I'm sorry, the Symphony No. 40 is that... Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. This is the one. So that's the one, that's what the one I heard in when I was four years old and I got obsessed with it. I apologize. Sorry, I'm so sorry.
哦，太感谢你了……打，打，打，打。抱歉，第40交响曲是……哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。就是这首。所以就是这首，这是我四岁时听到的那首，我当时就迷上了它。我道歉。抱歉，真的很抱歉。
I started playing it that. After that, I discovered Chopin and I was obsessed with Chopin and after that, well, I listened to my grandmother's record, so they had like... And after that, the Smiths. Beethoven, no, Beethoven, Bach. It was the Pixies, actually. And the Pixies. I love that. Hey, well, you guys, when you're on tour and you've got your set list and you're out there and you're playing the music and you've rehearsed it a certain way,
我开始弹奏它。在那之后，我发现了肖邦，我迷上了肖邦，在那之后，嗯，我听了我祖母的唱片，所以他们有……在那之后，是史密斯乐队。贝多芬，不，贝多芬，巴赫。其实是小妖精乐队。还有小妖精乐队。我喜欢那个。嘿，你们在巡演时，有自己的歌单，在外面演奏音乐，并且已经以某种方式排练过了，
talk to us about what the process is when you guys kind of absorb the energy of the audience, the kind of mood and tone and pace of each other and the combination of that to inform how differently you play a particular song on one night versus the next night. And the reason I ask is because there's a similarity between like actors when they do theater, you do the same material every night, but it changes every night per the audience's energy, per the other actor's energy. And so it'd be a completely different performance. Is that a signal that you guys send each other or is it something that you just kind of mutually feel? Can you explain that process a little bit? I like this. Sign language. Yeah, I mean, it's, no, it's...
跟我们聊聊当你们吸收观众的能量、彼此的情绪、基调和节奏，以及这些因素的结合如何影响你们在不同夜晚演奏同一首歌的方式时，这个过程是怎样的。我之所以这么问，是因为这和演员演戏很像，你们每晚表演同样的素材，但根据观众的能量、其他演员的能量，每晚都会有所不同。所以这会是一场完全不同的表演。这是你们彼此发送的信号，还是你们只是相互感受到的？能解释一下这个过程吗？我喜欢这个。手语。是的，我是说，不，它是……
Obviously, probably not something said, it's just something felt, yeah? No, 100%. I mean, I always like to, because a room always starts with a vibe and a lot of it's like depends on, you know, what's happening in the news and what people ate that day and what country you're in and what kind of like, so the audience comes in like with their vibe and you can tell a lot. Sean's vibe is he ate everything. Yeah, yeah, so sorry, go ahead. Right, so he's uncomfortable. So I'm shifty, I'm a little shifty, but I'm open. Stuff's unbuttoned. Yeah.
显然，可能不是说出来的，只是感受到的，对吧？不，百分之百。我是说，我总是喜欢，因为一个房间总是从一种氛围开始，很大程度上取决于，你知道，新闻里发生了什么，人们那天吃了什么，你在哪个国家，所以观众带着他们的氛围进来，你可以看出很多。肖恩的氛围是他吃了一切。是的，是的，抱歉，你继续。对，所以他很不舒服。所以我有点坐立不安，但我很开放。衣服扣子都没扣。是的。
Elf, just elfin out, you know? Yeah, probably not. What an elfie. By the way, you got that elf, bud. We're never going to stop. Also, like poetry is like a little bit like holographic, so like it does have all different colors, so like a word or a sentence can come out so many different ways. And so it's just, it's the same thing. It's just like today it shines like this and tomorrow it'll shine purple.
精灵，只是像个精灵一样，你知道吗？是的，可能不是。真是个小精灵。顺便说一句，你得到了那个精灵，伙计。我们永远不会停止。而且，诗歌有点像全息图，所以它确实有各种不同的颜色，所以一个词或一个句子可以以许多不同的方式呈现。所以这是一样的。就像今天它这样闪耀，明天它会闪耀出紫色。
And I'd imagine that's the exciting part of it, right, is waiting to sort of mutually feel those cues and... I thought you were going to say waiting for the lightning, that that's the exciting part. No, I mean, we're all there for the song, you know what I mean? So it's like the song, I sort of visualize it as the songs in between us and the audience and you sort of meet in the middle and... Do you ever get an audience that just blows and you like get pissed and you like... Yes, of course all the time. We're going to end early tonight because you guys are terrible. We played Montreux Jazz Fest and it's like Switzerland is just a bunch of extremely rich white people for the most part.
我想那正是令人兴奋的部分，对吧，等待着相互感受那些暗示，然后……我以为你要说等待闪电，那才是令人兴奋的部分。不，我是说，我们都是为了歌而来的，你明白我的意思吗？所以就像这首歌，我把它想象成歌曲在我们和观众之间，你们在中间相遇，然后……你们有没有遇到过那种观众，简直糟透了，让你很生气，然后你……是的，当然，一直都有。我们今晚要提前结束，因为你们太糟糕了。我们在蒙特勒爵士音乐节演出，那里基本上就是一群非常有钱的白人。
And they're very used to being entertained and you're at Montreux and the vibe is like, entertain me. And we're rock bands, we're playing and I'm just like trying to get a reaction out of the audience. I'm just like being kind of combative and at one point I'm like, and this is the last fucking time we're ever going to play this song in Switzerland and start the next song. And be like, and now this is the last time we're ever going to play this song in Switzerland. You said that or you're thinking that? I said it, every song, nothing. I got like, I didn't even get a boo, like I want them to boo me. Right, I wanted any reaction.
他们非常习惯被娱乐，你在蒙特勒，氛围就是，娱乐我。我们是摇滚乐队，我们在演奏，我只是想从观众那里得到反应。我表现得有点好斗，有一次我说，这是我们最后一次在瑞士演奏这首歌，然后开始下一首歌。然后说，现在这是我们最后一次在瑞士演奏这首歌。你说了还是你在想？我说了，每一首歌，什么都没有。我甚至没得到嘘声，我希望他们嘘我。对，我想要任何反应。
Just give me something and literally anything spit at me and just give me something. I would have been like, it's so good to be here at the Montneau snooze festival. Yeah, I'm going to say that for next time. And so wait, how did it end? So we finished and I'm like, and this was the last song that we ever played in Switzerland and leave the stage. And I see this guy sitting on the road case and I'm like, oh, he looks really familiar. And it was like Quincy Jones, like we have been watching the entire set just sitting there on side stage. And I went up to him and was like, hey, nice to meet you. Like that's so cool that I'm really sorry that that's the set that you saw.
给我点什么，真的什么都行，朝我吐口水，给我点什么。我会说，很高兴来到蒙特勒打瞌睡音乐节。是的，下次我要这么说。等等，最后怎么结束的？我们结束了，我说，这是我们在瑞士演奏的最后一首歌，然后离开舞台。我看到那个家伙坐在设备箱上，我想，哦，他看起来很眼熟。那是昆西·琼斯，我们一直在舞台侧面看着整场演出。我走过去对他说，嘿，很高兴见到你。那太酷了，我很抱歉你看到了那场演出。
That was like, maybe my worst time on stage in my entire life. And he's like, he's like, man, I work with Miles Davis. That was that was fine. Like, he was just like, he was like, that was like, whatever. He's like, Miles will play with his back to the audience. He hated those fuckers. Like, yeah, I love that. Boy, I can fucking relate to that.
那可能是我一生中最糟糕的舞台时光。他说，伙计，我和迈尔斯·戴维斯合作过。那没关系。他只是说，那没关系。他说，迈尔斯会背对着观众演奏。他讨厌那些混蛋。是的，我喜欢这个。天哪，我真他妈能感同身受。
These guys know I can be so grouchy. But if you buy a ticket to Arcade Fire, why wouldn't you be like, this is fucking awesome. Like, I don't understand. It's just cultural shit. I mean, they were probably like, it's like you meet people and they're like, the second song was too slow, but that was the best show of my life. I'm, you know, it's like people just, it's like, they can't help it. They can't help it. It's just, it's just how they are.
这些家伙知道我可以很暴躁。但如果你买了拱廊之火乐队的票，为什么不觉得这太棒了呢？我不明白。这只是文化问题。我是说，他们可能就像，就像你遇到一些人，他们说，第二首歌太慢了，但那是我一生中最棒的演出。你知道，就像人们，他们忍不住。他们忍不住。这就是他们的样子。
I'm going to be the dork and ask you a question. You probably answered a million times, but I've never heard it. So please indulge me. Tell me where the name of the band came from. Yeah, don't tell him, don't tell him. Yeah, I can't, I can't. Bob Dylan, I signed a blood pact with Bob Dylan that you're never supposed to answer a question like that. Not in your business, dude.
我要当个书呆子问你一个问题。你可能回答过一百万次了，但我从来没听过。所以请满足我。告诉我们乐队的名字是怎么来的。是的，别告诉他，别告诉他。是的，我不能，我不能。鲍勃·迪伦，我和鲍勃·迪伦签了血誓，你永远不应该回答这样的问题。不关你的事，伙计。
It has to do with Bob Dylan. I'm not a Bob Dylan. No, I'm just kidding. Oh, yeah. I, for a second there, I thought it was like a famous Bob Dylan song and I just amazed myself. You know, Arcade Fire, stirring up, she's in the basement, stirring up the Arcade Fire. So Woody Guthrie, yeah. No, I don't know, when I was, I was like a kid in, I just remember going to an arcade
这和鲍勃·迪伦有关。我不是鲍勃·迪伦。不，我开玩笑的。哦，是的。有一秒钟，我以为那是鲍勃·迪伦的一首名曲，我让自己惊呆了。你知道，拱廊之火，搅拌着，她在地下室，搅拌着拱廊之火。所以伍迪·格思里，是的。不，我不知道，当我还是个孩子的时候，我只记得去一个拱廊
when I was like four years old with like an older friend and my parents and just, it was like, I'm leaving my parent, you know, I don't know, just like being alone as a kid in a weird place like that. And it was like super futuristic in the, at the time it was like, what is this weird place with all these weird sounds? And it was like almost like an emotional, you know, it just sort of was like a weird touch tone and like almost like aesthetic reference or something like that. You guys, I, you know, I was thinking about your, first of all, kind of to what Jason
当我四岁的时候，和一个年长的朋友还有我父母一起，这就像，我要离开我的父母，你知道，我不知道，就像作为一个孩子独自在一个奇怪的地方。这在当时感觉超级未来感，就像，这是什么奇怪的地方，有所有这些奇怪的声音？这几乎就像一种情感，你知道，它只是一种奇怪的基调，几乎像是一种审美参考之类的。你们，我，你知道，我在想你们的，首先，有点像杰森
was saying before about, you guys, I've never seen you guys live. It's one of my big regrets, but it's going to happen this fall. I'm going to come and see you guys and you call yourself Canadian. I know, I know, but I haven't lived there in a long time. I know I am a pathetic Canadian, but I was thinking about especially with this new record with we, how I can almost visualize the, the crowds singing along with you guys to virtually every song. It felt so, you guys are just by nature of a collaborative band.
之前说的关于，你们，我从来没现场看过你们。这是我的一大遗憾，但今年秋天会实现的。我要去看你们，你们自称是加拿大人。我知道，我知道，但我已经很久没住在那里了。我知道我是一个可悲的加拿大人，但我一直在想，特别是这张新唱片《We》，我几乎可以想象观众和你们一起唱几乎每一首歌。这感觉太，你们天生就是一个合作型乐队。
There are different people and people coming in and out and sometimes the band expands and you have lots of people and that collaboration kind of almost extends kind of what these guys were saying. It extends to when you're in concert, feeding off the audience and in so many years. And that's kind of been a hallmark since day one. I mean, right. All those songs. I remember, I watched that video of you guys playing with Bowie when you guys did Wake
有不同的人，人们进进出出，有时乐队扩大，你们有很多成员，那种合作几乎延伸了这些家伙所说的。它延伸到你们在音乐会时，从观众那里汲取能量，这么多年来。这从第一天起就是一种标志。我是说，对。所有那些歌。我记得，我看了那个你们和鲍伊一起演奏的视频，当你们唱《Wake Up》的时候。
Up. I don't know what theater that was in where you did that. I think it was Radio City. Radio City, right? Yeah, it was. Yeah. I'm just like, there's something about it that's so like engaging and I wonder, was it always that intention like to be this kind of like just like this big, messy, collaborative
我不知道那是哪个剧院。我想是无线电城。无线电城，对吧？是的，确实是。是的。我只是觉得，它有一些东西非常吸引人，我想知道，这是否一直都是那种意图，成为这种像这样庞大、混乱、协作式的
kind of engagement. And by messy, I don't mean that I don't mean sloppy. I mean, that there's a lot of parts to it. I mean, we came up playing like DIY venues. So we were always, we were never on a stage like the first 40 times we played, we were always on the floor with the audience. And I remember just sort of like, I didn't really even need a mic for a lot of these rooms.
那种参与。我说混乱，并不是指邋遢。我的意思是，它有很多部分。我是说，我们是在DIY场地演出的。所以我们总是，我们前40次演出从来没在舞台上，我们总是在地板上和观众在一起。我记得就像，在很多这样的房间里，我甚至不需要麦克风。
It was like, you're playing to 50 people. And so like, I remember at one show, I just started walking, singing the song through the crowd and like walking to the back because it always at the back of a party, people are drinking beer and talking. And for playing a quiet song, you can't fucking hear anything. So I went over to where they were and was just playing the song in the back room. You just brought it to them. I just brought it to them because I, you know, it's a quiet song.
就像，你是在为50个人演奏。所以，我记得在一次演出中，我开始走动，在人群中唱着歌，走到后面，因为在派对的后面，人们总是喝着啤酒聊天。如果演奏一首安静的歌，你他妈什么都听不见。所以我走到他们所在的地方，在后屋演奏那首歌。你只是把它带给了他们。我只是把它带给了他们，因为我，你知道，这是一首安静的歌。
It's fine. You know, people like to talk at shows. Do you guys, you guys, last thing I want to say, ask you, it reminds me of, I was thinking about your first record. I think you guys did Conan. That record came out, what, in 2000, funeral came out 2004 or yeah, we did Conan and Letterman. And you did Conan and Letterman and Jeffrey Tambor, Jason and I were on a rest development at the time.
没关系。你知道，人们喜欢在演出时聊天。你们，你们，最后我想说，问你们，这让我想起，我在想你们的第一张唱片。我想你们上了柯南秀。那张唱片发行于，什么，2000年，葬礼发行于2004年，或者是的，我们上了柯南和莱特曼。你们上了柯南和莱特曼，杰弗里·塔伯，杰森和我在当时正在拍《发展受阻》。
And Jeffrey Tambor was on the show. That's right. That's right. And so you guys won't remember this, this part, which is Jeffrey said, I'm going to New York to do Conan to promote this show. And I said, there's this band. They've just released a record called Arcade Fire. And I gave him a CD and I said, well, you have them sign it.
杰弗里·塔伯上了那个节目。没错。没错。所以你们不会记得这一部分，就是杰弗里说，我要去纽约上柯南秀来宣传这个节目。我说，有一个乐队。他们刚发行了一张叫《拱廊之火》的唱片。我给了他一张CD，我说，好吧，让他们签个名。
And he said, okay. And so he came back and you guys, and I've got it somewhere in a box and you guys at Sun is like, we were told that we needed to sign this for you. You guys wrote it out and I have it. Oh, that's cool. That's cool. That's so cool. Me that Jeffrey gave back to me after that.
他说，好的。所以他回来了，你们，我把它放在盒子里某个地方，你们签的是，我们被告知需要为你签这个。你们写下来了，我有它。哦，那很酷。那很酷。太酷了。杰弗里在那之后还给了我。
That's really cool. Yeah. So that was. Yeah. Our guitar player, Richie, was obsessed with, what's the show that, what's the amazing show that he was on before on Larry Shader's? Oh yeah. Larry.
那真的很酷。是的。所以那是。是的。我们的吉他手，里奇，迷上了，他在拉里·桑德斯之前参加的那个精彩节目是什么？哦，是的。拉里。
It's brilliant. It's brilliant. He was obsessed with Larry Sanders and, and Jeffrey was getting his makeup done and Richie was sitting next to him. He's like, it's kind of like Larry Sanders, huh? And he was just like, just so non-plus to just give him the like, just like, just like dead eye. He gave him nothing.
太棒了。太棒了。他迷上了拉里·桑德斯，杰弗里正在化妆，里奇坐在他旁边。他说，这有点像拉里·桑德斯，对吧？他只是，非常冷淡，只是给了他那种，就像，死鱼眼。他什么都没给。
He just gave him the death, just the dead eyes and Richie was just like, his heart was like, oh my God, like, I think Jeffrey just like, like, I don't know what I was thinking. Why did I say that to him? He's like, he was just so mad at himself. That sounds like- Jeffrey was probably like, that's, that's, that's Jeffrey's humor. It's so good. The first, the first thing I ever said to him was the first day I met him on set at Rest of Development and, I met him and then as we were separate, I said, all right, well,
他只是给了他死亡，只是死鱼眼，里奇就像，他的心就像，天哪，我想杰弗里只是，我不知道我在想什么。我为什么要对他那样说？他就像，他对自己太生气了。这听起来像——杰弗里可能就像，那是，那是，那是杰弗里的幽默。太棒了。我对他说的第一件事是我在《发展受阻》片场见到他的第一天，我见到他，然后当我们分开时，我说，好吧，那么，
have a great day. He says, don't you fucking tell me what to do. I was entering a door at the same time as Jeffrey, exactly at the same time. And he goes, oh no, please, by billing, in order of billing. And he let me go first. It was the first time he met Amy, we were doing a rest, and she came to a table read my ex-wife and she came in there when I said, she said, I said, Jeffrey, this is Amy. And he goes, I didn't ask.
祝你有美好的一天。他说，别他妈告诉我该做什么。我和杰弗里同时进一扇门，完全同时。他说，哦不，请，按账单顺序。他让我先走。这是他第一次见到艾米，我们在拍《发展受阻》，她来参加剧本朗读，我的前妻，她进来时我说，我说，杰弗里，这是艾米。他说，我没问。
And he was so, and we both of us died. We fell to our knees. I mean, how, how much on a Rest of Development, how much is that like a, I always related to that, like a band when it's like a collective of, because it's like you have, I don't know, like when I would watch like a Monty Python, I always thought a Monty Python is a punk band. You know what I mean? Like, because it's like you have this, people are bouncing off each other, you're making
他太，我们俩都死了。我们跪倒在地。我是说，在《发展受阻》里，这有多像一个，我总是把它联系起来，就像一个乐队，当它是一个集体时，因为就像你有，我不知道，就像当我观看像蒙提·派森时，我总是认为蒙提·派森是一个朋克乐队。你知道我的意思吗？就像，因为你有这个，人们互相碰撞，你们在让
each other better. It's like you're trying to impress the other. I don't know. I was, I was wondered if that was. Somebody asked me the other, we were, maybe when we were doing the show, we were talking and saying, who do you try to, who do you do the performance for? I was with Jeff Bridges and I was saying, and I never answered it. And I was going to say my answer, which I'll tell you is in those moments, yeah, when,
彼此变得更好。就像你在试图给对方留下深刻印象。我不知道。我，我一直想知道那是否是。有人问我，我们，也许当我们做节目时，我们在谈论，你试图为谁表演？我和杰夫·布里吉斯在一起，我说，我从来没回答过。我要说我的答案，我会告诉你，在那些时刻，是的，当，
when Jason and David Cross and Tony Hale and I are doing a scene, I would always be trying to, we're riffing off each other, feeding off each other's energy. And I'm trying to make those guys laugh in the moment at how silly it is what we're doing. That's who I'm doing it for. Maybe the crew, definitely not the camera. I could give a shit. It's really these guys. I want Jason and Cross and Tony Hale to laugh.
当杰森、大卫·克罗斯、托尼·黑尔和我正在演一场戏时，我总是试图，我们在互相即兴发挥，从彼此的能量中汲取。我试图让那些家伙在那个时刻笑出来，因为我们做的事情太傻了。这就是我为谁做的。也许是剧组，绝对不是摄像机。我才不在乎。真的是这些家伙。我想让杰森、克罗斯和托尼·黑尔笑。
You know? I'm trying to ban too. I mean, it's like, cause you're playing, you're trying to get a rise out of the other people on the stage and, and then that energy gets transmitted, you know? And right. And it fuels, right? Like it. That's why I asked the thing about the audience.
你知道吗？我也在试图禁止。我是说，就像，因为你在演奏，你试图从舞台上的其他人那里得到反应，然后那种能量被传递，你知道吗？对。它助燃，对吧？就像。这就是我问关于观众的事情的原因。
Like when an audience like in Switzerland, would you just then start turning to each other and start playing for each other, you know? Cause it's like, we, it's, we always have. Yeah. No, for sure. I wanted to ask you. Sorry. So just to follow up, the last thing Sean about that I was getting to was I've always wanted
就像在瑞士那样的观众，你们会转而看向彼此，开始为彼此演奏吗，你知道吗？因为就像，我们，它，我们一直都有。是的。不，当然。我想问你。抱歉。所以只是跟进，肖恩，关于我刚才提到的最后一件事，我一直想
to know on that first record on funeral, uh, that song in a nice on Lumière and right near the red, right at the end where it goes into the guitar. It's always reminded me of the guitar at the end of love vigilantes on new order on low life. Have you ever heard, do you know that song? Of course. Yeah. I do.
知道在第一张唱片《葬礼》上，那首《In the Backseat》，就在最后，当它进入吉他部分时。它总是让我想起新秩序乐队《Low-Life》中《Love Vigilantes》结尾的吉他。你听过吗，你知道那首歌吗？当然。是的。我知道。
Yeah. It's a brilliant. And it's always reminded me and I've always been like, and I've, oh, I love new order. And then I loved you guys. I'm like, no wonder I love these guys because you guys remind me of a lot of bands and no bands because you're unique, but you also have pieces that we all have influences of stuff. Right.
是的。太棒了。它总是让我想起，我一直就像，而且我，哦，我爱新秩序。然后我爱你们。我想，难怪我爱这些家伙，因为你们让我想起很多乐队，又不像任何乐队，因为你们是独特的，但你们也有我们都有影响的东西。对。
So saying that, what of those kinds of bands that you guys like a part, you know, Well, I actually found a flyer that we made when we first met like in 2002, we were looking for musicians. And so it's like, you just, and it was like, I wrote the text like an apple, like it was shaped like whatever we made, we made a poster that was like this very, it's like so pretentious and almost it's like art school kind of, but you're just, we didn't want to just make a poster because we wanted to make something that was like, we thought was cool so that the person who read it, and it was like our influences that we, it was like looking for
所以这么说，你们喜欢的那些乐队，你们，你知道，嗯，我实际上发现了一张我们刚见面时制作的传单，大概在2002年，我们在寻找音乐家。所以就像，你只是，它就像，我写了文字，像一个苹果，就像它形状像无论我们做了什么，我们做了一张海报，就像这个非常，它太自命不凡了，几乎就像艺术学校那种，但你只是，我们不想只是做一张海报，因为我们想做一些我们认为很酷的东西，这样读到它的人，它就像我们的影响，我们，它就像寻找
musicians and it was like New Order was one of them, Pixies, Dylan. And then it was like Motown and Debussy and Arvo part. That was like our, those are our influence list. You know what I mean? Wow. And then nobody, nobody, nobody took the number. Nobody took the number. Not one person.
音乐家，它就像新秩序是其中之一，小妖精，迪伦。然后它就像摩城唱片、德彪西和阿沃·帕特。那就是我们的，那是我们的影响列表。你知道我的意思吗？哇。然后没有人，没有人，没有人拿那个号码。没有人拿那个号码。一个人都没有。
No, not one person. They're like, they're like, these guys are too, this is too broad. This is crazy. They want to. It doesn't make sense. These things don't go together. They're into everything. Yeah.
不，一个人都没有。他们就像，他们就像，这些家伙太，这太广泛了。这太疯狂了。他们想要。这说不通。这些东西不搭。他们什么都喜欢。是的。
It's not everything though. It makes sense. There's a thread. Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show. There's such a great fullness to your music too. There is, there is, it is truly like, it has that ensemble sound.
不过不是什么都喜欢。这说得通。有一条线索。是的。我们马上回来。回到节目。你们的音乐有一种很棒的丰满感。有，有，它确实像，它有那种合奏的声音。
You're not surprised if a horn section comes through or, you know, or strings or, I always love that about Pink Floyd always was, there was always just, as you said earlier, like a soundscape as opposed to, well, it's just four instruments and it's four, four time. And it's somewhat of a predictable rhythm to it. We're filmmakers. Ultimately, it's like we think of it that way. Yeah. It's still like, I always think like, I listened to a lot of Dylan too when I was a teenager.
如果管乐部分出现，或者，你知道，或者弦乐，你不会感到惊讶，我一直喜欢平克·弗洛伊德的那一点，总是，正如你刚才所说，像一个音景，而不是，嗯，它只是四种乐器，它是四四拍。而且节奏有点可预测。我们是电影制作人。归根结底，我们是那样想的。是的。它仍然像，我总是想，我十几岁时也听了很多迪伦。
I listened to the cure a lot. I mentioned the Smiths were like one of my all time favorite bands. And at the same time, I went to- Cure is huge for me. Cure. Huge. That EP that, what was it, Japanese whispers. And then they had, and then, but I also went to 15 dead shows, but I'm not a dead head,
我听了很多治疗乐队。我提到史密斯乐队是我最喜欢的乐队之一。同时，我去了——治疗乐队对我来说太大了。治疗乐队。巨大。那张EP，是什么，日本耳语。然后他们有，然后，但我还去了15场死之华的演出，但我不是死忠粉，
but I appreciated Jerry Garcia. But at the same time, I was like, I'm really into, you know, just all kinds of like indie. And I think that that's important, right? Like to have like, you don't have to be like just into this genre or just into this genre. Makes you a better musician. I'm sure. Yeah. Like Sean, you don't have to just listen to Erasure.
但我欣赏杰瑞·加西亚。但同时，我就像，我真的很喜欢，你知道，各种各样的独立音乐。我认为这很重要，对吧？就像你不必只喜欢这种流派或只喜欢那种流派。这让你成为更好的音乐家。我肯定。是的。就像肖恩，你不必只听Erasure。
In the Pesh mode. Sorry. In the Pesh mode. So wait. But wait. I love the Pesh too. Well, that was one of my first big shows, the Pesh was, I love the Pesh, but I love them everywhere.
赶时髦乐队。抱歉。赶时髦乐队。所以等等。但是等等。我也爱赶时髦乐队。嗯，那是我的第一场大演出之一，赶时髦乐队，我爱赶时髦乐队，但我到处都爱他们。
Every word, every song. Who said the keyboard player just died, right? Andy Fletcher. Yeah. Andy Fletcher died. Yeah. But I have a question about your voice because, you know, when I was younger, I didn't understand the technique of singing or anything or musicianship or really anything.
每一个字，每一首歌。谁说键盘手刚去世，对吧？安迪·弗莱彻。是的。安迪·弗莱彻去世了。是的。但我有一个关于你声音的问题，因为，你知道，当我年轻的时候，我不懂唱歌的技巧，或者任何东西，或者音乐素养，或者真的任何东西。
I would go, you know, I'd watch bands on TV or on music videos or on tour or whatever. And I didn't quite, I was like, wow, that's amazing that they can scream or sing or do whatever with their voice. And then you get older and you learn how the instrument works and the training that needs and the warmups and all the stuff that you don't ever see musicians do or singers do off to the side. And then today I'll watch like, you know, something on TV, I'm like, how can they do that?
我会去，你知道，我会看电视上的乐队，或者音乐录影带，或者巡演，或者其他什么。我不太明白，我当时想，哇，他们能尖叫或唱歌或用他们的声音做任何事，真是太神奇了。然后你变老了，你学会了乐器是如何工作的，需要的训练，热身，以及所有你在侧面看不到音乐家或歌手做的事情。然后今天我会看，你知道，电视上的东西，我想，他们怎么能那样做？
How can they sing like that night after night after night? Aren't they ruining their vocal chords or whatever? So do you have any kind of things that you do? Was there ever a moment where you're like, wow, I really got to take care of my instrument here in my throat? Because both of you guys belted out to a lot. Yeah. I mean, Regine had nodules when I met her from jazz school.
他们怎么能那样夜复一夜地唱歌？他们不是在毁掉他们的声带吗？所以你有什么做的事情吗？有没有那么一刻，你觉得，哇，我真的得照顾好我的乐器，我的喉咙？因为你们俩都唱得很大声。是的。我是说，我遇到Regine时，她因为爵士学校有声带小结。
Oh, yeah. I met Regine and she had, and the next day she got braces, like one week later she got braces and then had vocal cord surgery and couldn't talk for like two months. No way. Yeah, no way. Wow. You're like, I'm in. I am in.
哦，是的。我遇到了Regine，她有，第二天她就戴上了牙套，大概一周后她戴上了牙套，然后做了声带手术，大概两个月不能说话。不会吧。是的，不会吧。哇。你就像，我加入了。我加入了。
Yeah. Yeah. But was there a moment that where you're like, oh, shit, I got to really kind of maybe go see a teacher now, now that I'm like getting, I'm doing more work as a singer and stuff because you never learned or do you not even think about that? You never did it. There was a point, I mean, I sent, particularly on the first record, like I sang like the world was every single fucking time we played.
是的。是的。但有没有那么一刻，你觉得，哦，该死，我现在真的得去找个老师了，既然我作为一个歌手做了更多的工作之类的，因为你从来没学过，或者你根本没想过那个？你从来没做过。有那么一点，我是说，我送，特别是在第一张唱片上，就像我唱得好像世界是每一次我们他妈的演奏。
I was saying like every second of it, the world was going to end the next second, you know. The first two tours, you were like a ghost. You were like. I was a ghost. You're like so pale and just kind of upset. I had, I had really horrible sinus infections. I think I was sick for four years, like pretty much non-stop sick the entire time.
我唱得好像每一秒，世界下一秒就要结束了，你知道。前两次巡演，你就像个鬼魂。你就像。我是一个鬼魂。你看起来那么苍白，只是有点难过。我，我得了非常可怕的鼻窦感染。我想我病了四年，就像基本上不停地病了整个时间。
Wow. And just singing, like we would always start with wake up and I mean, like back in the day, we'd, there'd be seven of us and we'd be playing to six people and we would still fucking sing it like it was the fucking end of the world and it was always the first song. So we would come out, set up our instruments and like, I remember seeing a video of us in Austin back in the day, we're playing some little club and we're loading in the equipment ourselves. We're just like, look white and just like sweat pouring down our face.
哇。只是唱歌，就像我们总是从《Wake Up》开始，我是说，就像过去，我们有七个人，我们为六个人演奏，我们仍然他妈的唱得好像世界末日一样，而且它总是第一首歌。所以我们会出来，架好我们的乐器，就像，我记得看到一个我们在奥斯汀过去的视频，我们在一个小俱乐部演奏，我们自己装载设备。我们只是，看起来很白，汗水顺着脸流下来。
We just arrived from like a 400 mile drive. Oh, I remember that. Like load in our crap in front of the audience, the audience is already there. And then we're, I'm just like, we're, we've just turned on the instruments. I'm like, more fucking voice, more fucking voice, more fucking voice. That's too much. It's feeding back. Okay.
我们刚从400英里的车程赶来。哦，我记得那个。就像在观众面前装载我们的垃圾，观众已经在那里了。然后我们，我只是，我们刚打开乐器。我就像，更多他妈的声音，更多他妈的声音，更多他妈的声音。那太多了。它在反馈。好的。
Good. And then we're like, one, two, three, four. I was like, just like, just starting there. Like that's where we started. Especially when you get done, I guess it'll just have to adjust and it's like insane. Like the, both of you guys are just like going for it. So I burned out. I, I mean, I was sick and singing every night and at one point on Neon Bible, second record,
好的。然后我们就像，一，二，三，四。我当时就像，只是像，就在那里开始。就像那是我们开始的地方。特别是当你做完的时候，我想它只会调整，这太疯狂了。就像，你们俩都只是全力以赴。所以我烧坏了。我，我是说，我病了，每晚都在唱歌，在《Neon Bible》第二张唱片时，
we were playing in Norway and we came out and I was just like, there's nothing, not a, not a fucking sound. And I basically went and had sign of surgery. In Norway? No, I wish. I wish. No, in Montreal. Okay.
我们在挪威演出，我们出来，我只是，什么都没有，没有他妈的声音。我基本上去了，做了鼻窦手术。在挪威？不，我希望。我希望。不，在蒙特利尔。好的。
Cause it was like one 1,000th of the cost of doing in New York and so then it was like $200, please. And then I, I had the surgery and then after that, I, I kind of realized I'd never lost my voice. Like I was just, I was losing my voice cause I was sick and now I don't, cause I did all the singing coach crap and I was always losing my voice and every singing coach is like, I'm the only one who knows the secrets of singing and like my, my method, which is passed down to me by the two tonic nights.
因为那是在纽约做的成本的千分之一，所以当时是200美元，请。然后我，我做了手术，在那之后，我，我意识到我从来没失去过我的声音。就像我只是，我失去声音是因为我病了，现在我没有了，因为我做了所有那些声乐教练的垃圾，我总是失去声音，每个声乐教练都像，我是唯一知道唱歌秘密的人，就像我的，我的方法，这是条顿骑士传给我的。
Right. By my book and my tent. Get my oils. Whatever. Did you use my oils? Like it's always like this, like tell no one of the oils I gave you. I was at that, I was at that show in Berlin with you two guys when, when Bono lost his voice and after three songs, it was so scary and it was like, yeah, it's terrifying, right?
对。买我的书和我的帐篷。用我的油。无论什么。你用过我的油吗？就像总是这样，就像不要告诉任何人我给你的油。我和你们两个在柏林的那场演出时，当波诺失去声音，三首歌之后，太可怕了，就像，是的，很恐怖，对吧？
You must, it's scary when you're losing it. How do you stay healthy now, when, when you guys are on the road and I imagine it would be hard to have any sort of rhythm of proper stuff to eat or sleep or how diligent are you with the food? Here we go. Yeah. The travel is crazy. Yeah.
当你失去它时，你一定会害怕。你们现在在路上时怎么保持健康，我想很难有任何规律的饮食或睡眠，或者你们对食物有多勤奋？开始了。是的。旅行太疯狂了。是的。
I mean. Jason wants to know if you have access to salads cause he's trying to think about himself on tour. Would there be an hour? We have snacks. There's always hummus and carrots. You know, every backstage. Jason's in.
我是说。杰森想知道你们是否有沙拉，因为他正在考虑自己在巡演时的情况。会有一个小时吗？我们有零食。总是有鹰嘴豆泥和胡萝卜。你知道，每个后台。杰森加入了。
All right. I'm in. And then. Do you have access to a handful of nuts? Yes. Would that be possible? Yeah. You can get some nuts.
好的。我加入了。然后。你们有几把坚果吗？是的。那可能吗？是的。你可以弄点坚果。
Even out the blood sugar. And then, so your son, what happens during the school year when you guys are on tour? Do you just schedule your tours so it's only during the summer? I mean, it's kind of a brave new world now. It's like we, it's our, this will be our first time touring since COVID and it's all, it's you know, it's kind of happening, but it's also like a little bit terrifying. It's like, like the health perspective. I mean, not getting COVID cause I just had it and it was like no big deal.
平衡血糖。然后，所以你的儿子，当你们巡演时，学年期间发生了什么？你们只是把巡演安排在夏天吗？我是说，现在是一个勇敢的新世界。就像我们，这是我们自COVID以来的第一次巡演，它，你知道，它正在发生，但它也有一点点恐怖。就像，就像健康的角度。我是说，没得COVID，因为我刚得过，感觉没什么大不了的。
It was like totally fine. Right. It just boosted and everything. You were psyched. Be honest. We were texting and you were kind of psyched. I was psyched. Yeah.
感觉完全没问题。对。只是加强了，一切。你很兴奋。说实话。我们在发短信，你有点兴奋。我很兴奋。是的。
I was like, I'm, I'm about to watch Blade Runner and then alien and alien too. With no kill. I love it. Yeah. Eugene, were you psyched? Were you psyched also? Uh, you know, not particularly, but she's the one, she's one of the last ones. She still never had it.
我当时就像，我，我正要看《银翼杀手》，然后是《异形》和《异形2》。没有杀戮。我喜欢。是的。Regine，你兴奋吗？你也兴奋吗？呃，你知道，不是特别，但她是那个，她是最后几个之一。她从来没得过。
I didn't get it. Oh really? Yeah. I didn't get it. I don't know. Sean and I didn't get it either. I don't know. I'll pick right here.
我没得。哦真的吗？是的。我没得。我不知道。肖恩和我也没得。我不知道。我选这里。
Thanks man. Uh, yeah, but it is a great, but, but you are, yeah, I guess because of COVID and stuff, you're probably, your son was too young and now you're going to have to figure out what that is like going on tour and kids. We talk about it a lot because we do, Jason, I have three, three boys and Jason has two girls and where it's always like a, that's always the thing of like what, you know, with kids and managing that and their school and work and that balance and what are you doing? And it's, it's just, it's the number one question.
谢谢伙计。呃，是的，但这是一个伟大的，但是，但你是，是的，我想因为COVID之类的，你可能，你的儿子太小了，现在你将不得不弄清楚带着孩子巡演是什么感觉。我们经常谈论它，因为我们，杰森，我有三个，三个男孩，杰森有两个女孩，我们总是像，那总是关于，你知道，带着孩子，管理那个，他们的学校和工作，以及那种平衡，你们在做什么？而且，这只是，这是头号问题。
I think what's cool now is that because of the pandemic and the schools, at least the school where he goes, got really organized in terms of the remote and the curriculum. So that it's not, it's not like a brand new thing. If we tell him he has to come out for a few days, you know, that's great. I feel like our job as parents is mostly to prepare him for a world which will be insane and constantly changing and you better be able to take a hit because shit is going to be gnarly. So like,
我认为现在很酷的是，因为大流行和学校，至少他去的学校，在远程和课程方面变得非常有组织。所以它不是，它不是什么全新的东西。如果我们告诉他他必须出来几天，你知道，那太棒了。我觉得我们作为父母的工作主要是让他为一个疯狂且不断变化的世界做好准备，你最好能承受打击，因为事情会变得很棘手。所以就像，
You mean, you mean this planet that we lit on fire and left for them? The whole fucking thing is just, I mean, like the whole war raging in Europe and climate change and like the technology, like all of the companies are all just trying to remove humans. So it's like no one, no one's going to, it's just going to be, I think in the future, it's like you're just going to have to be really nimble and like able to like mix it up and adapt. And for sure.
你是说，你是说这个我们点燃并留给他们的星球？整个他妈的事情只是，我是说，就像整个在欧洲肆虐的战争和气候变化，以及技术，就像所有的公司都只是试图消灭人类。所以就像没有人，没有人会，我认为在未来，它就像你只是必须非常灵活，并且能够像混合起来并适应。而且肯定。
So being on tour is a good training ground. Tour is awesome. It's a great training ground for that. You guys wrote that great tune, look out kid on your new record on Wee. Sort of about that. Yeah. Not, not by the way, not on Wee, on Wee, not E-N-N-U-I. Oh, you really do speak French.
所以巡演是一个很好的训练场。巡演太棒了。这是一个很好的训练场。你们写了那首很棒的曲子，《Lookout Kid》，在你们的新唱片《We》上。有点关于那个。是的。顺便说一句，不是在《We》上，在《We》上，不是E-N-N-U-I。哦，你真的会说法语。
Oh, he speaks French fluently. But I am also suffering from a great deal of on Wee these days. You probably heard earlier when, before you guys got on, it's been weird times, but yeah, you wrote about it in Regine, look out kid, it's kind of exactly about that you were saying? Yeah. I mean, it's just like talking to my son and being like shit's going to be pretty nerly and, but I love you a lot and it's like kind of about unconditional love basically, like in the face of like, just the inevitability of like, I don't know how high school was
哦，他法语说得很流利。但我最近也遭受了大量的无聊。你可能早些时候听到了，在你们上来之前，那是奇怪的时光，但是的，你们写了它，Regine，《Lookout Kid》，它基本上就是你说的那个？是的。我是说，它就像和我儿子说话，就像事情会变得很棘手，但是我很爱你，它基本上是关于无条件的爱，就像面对，只是不可避免的，就像，我不知道高中是怎么样的
for you guys, but that shit was gnarly for me. The best. I mean, the worst. It was so rough. I'm like, I'm trying to imagine being in high school now. I'm just like. No way. No way.
对你们来说，但那对我来说很棘手。最好。我是说，最坏。太粗糙了。我就像，我试图想象现在上高中。我只是。不会吧。不会吧。
I hated it. I loved it. What got you guys down to New Orleans? What was the, aside from, it was United, I think it was, or Delta, probably. Yeah. Delta, American. Was it the music influence down there, or was it something less obvious than that? Well, Regine's family is from Haiti and the whole French-Canadian thing and when we first,
我讨厌它。我爱它。是什么让你们去了新奥尔良？除了，是联合航空，我想，或者达美航空，可能。是的。达美，美国。是因为那里的音乐影响，还是比那更不明显的东西？嗯，Regine的家人来自海地，还有整个法裔加拿大的事情，当我们第一次，
I grew up in Houston. No, I was just thinking about you guys, everybody saying like, oh yeah, high school is so bad and who did you like it? I didn't like it. I hated it. It's like, whoever liked it, like, no one, does anyone. Sean, Sean liked it. Sean liked it.
我在休斯顿长大。不，我只是在想你们，每个人都说，哦，是的，高中太糟糕了，你喜欢谁？我不喜欢。我讨厌它。就像，谁喜欢它，就像，没有人，有人吗。肖恩，肖恩喜欢它。肖恩喜欢它。
I loved it. We loved it. High school? Yeah. Wow. He peaked. He peaked. That was his, that was the highlight.
我爱它。我们爱它。高中？是的。哇。他达到了顶峰。他达到了顶峰。那是他的，那是亮点。
That was the highlight. But he was, you have to understand, his father left, that's a whole other story. The bar was. Once you talk to him long enough, you'll get it. No, there was awesome shit in high school. I really, like, I, you know, there are aspects of high school that were amazing. Like I loved, I loved, just, I mean, I first read, you know, when I first read like, just the beatnecks and the first, you know, just literature and art.
那是亮点。但他，你必须明白，他父亲离开了，那是另一个故事。标准是。一旦你和他谈得够久，你就会明白。不，高中里有很棒的事情。我真的，就像，我，你知道，高中里有一些方面是惊人的。就像我爱，我爱，只是，我是说，我第一次读，你知道，当我第一次读像，只是垮掉的一代和第一，你知道，只是文学和艺术。
But that shit, you say him here. Like I read on the road when I was 17 and I was like, I got to leave where I'm at. But that wasn't stuff I did in high school. That was stuff I did on my own. Yeah. Wait, wait, wait. First of all, just on the last thing on We, end of the empire, man, I don't know when you wrote that song.
但那东西，你在这里说他。就像我17岁时读了《在路上》，我当时就像，我必须离开我现在的地方。但那不是我在高中做的事情。那是我自己做的事情。是的。等等，等等，等等。首先，只是关于《We》的最后一件事，《End of the Empire》，伙计，我不知道你什么时候写的那首歌。
It feels like you wrote it today. And I don't know, at least like it feels every time I listen to it, it feels, it just puts me right in the present in this really remarkable way. Talk to me a little bit about that, that song, because it's just, I just connect with it so much. I mean, it's, it's kind of, it's a four, four parts. So, so it's like kind of, it's kind of the most ambitious thing we've done in a lot of ways.
感觉你今天写的。我不知道，至少就像每次我听它时，它感觉，它只是以这种非常显著的方式把我带到了现在。跟我聊聊那首歌，因为我，我只是和它联系太深了。我是说，它，它有点，它是一个四，四部分。所以，所以它就像有点，它有点像我们在很多方面做过的最雄心勃勃的事情。
I mean, it's nine and a half minutes. But it's not, it's not Prague, you know, I never really liked Prague music, but it's like, I mean, I love Radiohead in high school, like a, you know, a paranoid Android probably has like a little bit of a, of a influence in there as well. But it was just sort of looking, we started it before the pandemic. So the first couple parts lyrically were kind of the world, America was just feeling pretty heavy there for, for a while, like before the election, before the pandemic just really felt like just energetically, like, like in America, I was like, man, this is a really
我是说，它有九分半钟。但它不是，它不是前卫摇滚，你知道，我从来没真正喜欢过前卫音乐，但它就像，我是说，我高中时喜欢电台司令，就像一个，你知道，一个《Paranoid Android》可能也有点，有点影响在里面。但它只是有点看着，我们在大流行之前就开始了。所以前几部分在歌词上有点像世界，美国当时感觉很沉重，有一段时间，就像选举前，大流行之前，真的感觉就像只是在能量上，就像，在美国，我当时就像，伙计，这是一个非常
dark, heavy cloud, just like you're constantly being like barraged by all this stuff. And so it was just sort of like that, like just sort of like a reckoning with ourselves about, you know, it's been a, been a good ride, but this shit is, you know, not, not, not going in the best direction. So a bit of that. And then the world kind of ended. And the fourth part is like kind of, there's a black hole in the middle of our galaxy called Sagittarius A.
黑暗，沉重的云，就像你不断地被所有这些东西轰炸。所以它只是有点像那样，就像只是有点像关于我们自己的清算，你知道，这是一次，这是一次很好的旅程，但这东西是，你知道，不，不，不朝着最好的方向发展。所以有点那个。然后世界结束了。第四部分就像有点，在我们的银河系中间有一个黑洞，叫人马座A。
And I read an article about it. Yeah. And I was just sort of like, I was, there was something about the image of this black hole in the middle of everything that just, I, I was just trying to write that lyrically write that part for a long time. And Regine, like we recorded that, just the two of us, it was Mardi Gras day during the pandemic when Mardi Gras didn't happen, which is a really eerie, really like it's such a spiritual day and it's just like this, the streets are empty in New Orleans.
我读过一篇关于它的文章。是的。我当时就觉得，关于这首歌中间那个黑洞的意象，我一直试图在歌词中写出那一部分，写了很久。Regine，我们录制那段时，只有我们俩。那是疫情期间的狂欢节那天，当时狂欢节并没有举行，那感觉真的很诡异，那本该是一个非常神圣的日子，但在新奥尔良，街道却空无一人。
It's like this really like deep spiritual kind of energy and like nothing, the sound of nothing, no horns playing, no one in the streets. And yeah, we just recorded that in our living room, the fourth part. Yeah. And the part two is from 20 years ago, the second part, we know that it's time to go. That is from like, when I live on an apartment, we didn't even live together, like he lived a few blocks away. And I,
那是一种非常深沉、神圣的能量，什么都没有，没有号角声，街上也没有人。是的，我们就在客厅里录制了那第四部分。是的。而第二部分是20年前写的，我们知道是时候离开了。那是我住在一个公寓时写的，我们当时甚至还没住在一起，他住在几个街区外，而我，
Did you have braces at the time? Yes. I did have braces at the time. And I played it on this little organ that I bought for like a hundred bucks or something, or a few hundred bucks maybe. And I love that. Regine, what is that?
你当时戴牙套了吗？是的，我当时确实戴着牙套。我用我花了一百美元左右，或者几百美元买的小风琴弹奏了它。我很喜欢那个。Regine，那是什么？
And I know it's time to go. Yeah. Send the news on the radio. One last round before we go. One through the pale atmospheric glow. And the oxygen's getting low. Sing a song that we used to know. Oh, you're wrong key.
我知道是时候离开了。是的。在收音机里听到新闻。在我们离开前最后一轮。穿过苍白的氛围光。氧气正在减少。唱一首我们曾经熟悉的歌。哦，你跑调了。
One last round before we go. One last round before we go. All the alcoholics, let's go. And we know that it's time to go. Heard the news on the radio. One last round before we go. Bye everyone. Regine and win.
在我们离开前最后一轮。在我们离开前最后一轮。所有的酒鬼们，我们走吧。我们知道是时候离开了。在收音机里听到新闻。在我们离开前最后一轮。再见大家。Regine和Win。
You guys, you gotta go. I love that song. That's a first for us. That's awesome. That's really cool. You guys, thank you. We've taken up so much of your time. We've taken, we've, thank you very generous.
你们得走了。我很喜欢那首歌。这对我们来说是第一次。太棒了。真的很酷。你们，谢谢。我们占用了你们太多时间。我们占用了，我们，谢谢，你们太慷慨了。
And we know that it's time to go. Heard the news on the radio. Sing, Bayman. All the elves. All the elves. Thank you. Thank you for giving us elf bods. Thank you for giving us all your music.
我们知道是时候离开了。在收音机里听到新闻。唱吧，Bateman。所有的精灵。所有的精灵。谢谢。谢谢你们给了我们精灵的身材。谢谢你们给了我们所有的音乐。
Thank you for giving us your time. Hashtag elf bod, hashtag COVID. Hashtag relatable. Hashtag tell your son hi from Batman. Yeah. Nine pack. And Bateman. Yeah.
谢谢你们给了我们时间。标签：精灵身材，标签：新冠。标签：有共鸣。标签：代我向Bateman问好。是的。九块腹肌。还有Bateman。是的。
And Bateman. That's good. Honestly, just thank you guys so much. You guys should do this where you like talk to a whole bunch of different people. Oh my God. You guys have a great chemistry. It's really funny. Like you should just like hang out.
还有Bateman。那很好。老实说，真的非常感谢你们。你们应该做这个节目，去和各种各样的人聊天。天哪。你们俩化学反应太好了。真的很有趣。你们应该多聚聚。
Do this thing where you like shoot the shit and then surprise people with. I don't think anyone would ever listen. No, you should. You should do it. It's great. I don't think. Oh my God. Thanks you guys.
做这种闲聊节目，然后给人们惊喜。我觉得没人会听。不，你们应该做。你们应该做。这很棒。我不觉得。天哪，谢谢你们。
Huge fans. You guys are amazing. Amazing. When I am, when I need to go to sleep, I use a sleep pill. Do you guys have to do that crap or do they like, you know, in podcasting or you have to just do that shit? Oh yeah. Can you do one now?
超级粉丝。你们太棒了。太棒了。当我需要睡觉时，我会用助眠药。你们也得做那种事吗，还是在播客里，你们必须得做那种事？哦，是的。你们现在能做一个吗？
Can I hear you guys do one? Oh yeah. What are you doing? Doing that for their album right now, Will. Yeah. Doing that for our album. Yeah. You have such a great voice.
我能听听你们做一个吗？哦，是的。你们在做什么？Will，我们正在为我们的专辑做那个。是的，为我们的专辑做那个。是的。你的声音真好听。
So this summer, arcade fire. And who do you want to play with? Sean Hayes and the arcade fire this summer at the Molson Burbell Center. I don't know what they call it now. Just do like a promo. Give us a wee one. Give us like a good like just give us. Arcade fire would be great name for like a sitcom if you do like then on an all new
所以今年夏天，Arcade Fire。你想和谁一起演出？Sean Hayes和Arcade Fire今年夏天在Molson中心。我不知道他们现在叫什么名字。就做一个宣传吧。给我们来一个小片段。给我们来一个好的，就给我们。Arcade Fire作为一个情景喜剧的名字会很棒，如果你做的话，然后在一个全新的
arcade fire, win and regime come home and their house is not exactly as they remember it. They've been super depressed about the state of the world. Previously on arcade fire. Previously. Previously. Oh, you guys, we could do this forever. I can't wait to join you on stage and sing that song and the empire with you on stage
Arcade Fire，Win和Regine回家了，但他们的房子和他们记忆中的不太一样。他们对世界现状感到非常沮丧。Arcade Fire前情提要。前情提要。前情提要。哦，你们，我们可以永远这样下去。我迫不及待地想和你们一起上台，和你们一起唱那首《The Empire》
is going to be epic. And it's going to be amazing. Yeah. No, honestly, you guys, thank you so much. It's been amazing. And thanks for giving us your time. Yeah. Thank you guys very, very much.
那将会是史诗级的。那将会非常棒。是的。不，老实说，你们，非常感谢。这太棒了。谢谢你们给了我们时间。是的，非常非常感谢你们。
Thank you. Guys, now Willie, that seemed to be a beautiful elixir for your day. Right there. That changed. Right there. Yeah. Yeah. My whole chemistry.
谢谢。伙计们，Willie，那对你的一天来说似乎是一种美丽的灵丹妙药。就在那儿。那改变了。就在那儿。是的。是的。我的整个化学反应。
Absolutely. Of course. It just takes a little something like that. That's what music can do. It was so impactful. I can't believe we just saying that all of us. I know. That's cool.
绝对是。当然。只需要一点点那样的东西。这就是音乐能做到的。它太有影响力了。我不敢相信我们刚才一起唱了那首歌。我知道。那很酷。
I can't believe we just say the empire with those guys with one in regime. Yeah. You know, I did want to mention not in front of them, but I will to you guys, whenever somebody they're not listening. I wasn't listening. They won't. They're not listening. Yeah.
我不敢相信我们刚才和那些家伙，和Win与Regine一起唱了《The Empire》。是的。你知道，我确实想提一下，不是在他们面前，但我会告诉你们，每当有人，他们没在听。我没在听。他们不会。他们没在听。是的。
Go ahead. No, I wanted to tell you whenever somebody brings up New Orleans, I think about the four way I had there. I associate that same with the four way. God damn, I wish they were still on. How many dudes? How many girls? Yeah.
说吧。不，我想告诉你，每当有人提起新奥尔良，我就想到我在那儿经历的四人行。我把那首歌和四人行联系在一起。该死，我真希望他们还在播。多少个男的？多少个女的？是的。
What? No, I'll do just four dudes. Yeah. Four dudes. Yeah. Years and years and years ago. I'm not sure that's a four way. I think it's just a train.
什么？不，我只会做四个男的。是的。四个男的。是的。那是很多年前的事了。我不确定那算不算四人行。我觉得那只是火车。
You know what the great thing about a four way, it's a train, but you know, the great thing is you have two lucky peers. Yeah. Right. So that's the good news. Train. Everybody hop on. You just don't want to be the caboose or you do want to be the caboose or you don't
你知道四人行的伟大之处吗，它是火车，但你知道，伟大之处在于你有两个幸运的同伴。是的。对吧。所以那是好消息。火车。大家都跳上来。你只是不想成为最后一节车厢，或者你想成为最后一节车厢，或者你不想
know. Well, you don't want to be the caboose in a, in one of the human centipede that you don't want to be the caboose. No, that you do not want that. Because you're getting the waste of all the other people. Have you ever thought about where you want to be on a human centipede? Can I be one of the shoes? You want to be in the front.
知道。嗯，你不想在《人体蜈蚣》里成为最后一节车厢，你不想成为最后一节。不，你绝对不想那样。因为你会得到所有其他人的排泄物。你有没有想过你想在《人体蜈蚣》的什么位置？我可以当鞋子吗？你想在最前面。
By the way, just, you know, you want to be the first guy. You got to sign up. You got to sign up early. Well, somebody is sewed to your ass, but it doesn't. I mean, that, believe me, it's the best case scenario. Now, Willie, when they say careful about meeting your heroes, I would imagine that that didn't over-delivered. Yeah, they seem so lovely and funny and like great to hang out with.
顺便说一句，你知道，你想成为第一个人。你得报名。你得尽早报名。嗯，有人缝在你的屁股上，但这并不。我是说，相信我，这是最好的情况。现在，Willie，当他们说小心见到你的偶像时，我想象那并没有让人失望。是的，他们看起来那么可爱、有趣，而且相处起来很棒。
They over-delivered. And like I said, I, you know, because I knew we were going to have them on and they graciously and generously sent me their record a few months ago before it came out. And I, like I said, it was so impactful and I ended up listening to it so much and I had to reach out. And so Michael and Bennett and Robert, somebody got me their number and I ended up texting with both on a chain with both winning regime for a while. And we had a really great exchange.
他们超出了预期。就像我说的，你知道，因为我知道我们要邀请他们，他们几个月前在唱片发行前就慷慨地把唱片寄给了我。就像我说的，它太有影响力了，我最后听了很多遍，我不得不联系他们。所以Michael、Bennett和Robert，有人给了我他们的号码，我最后和Win与Regine在群聊里发了一段时间短信。我们有很好的交流。
And then, and then they had to cancel. And then so when did I started texting when he got sick and he wasn't really sick, but he was just at home and then we, he started talking about it when I said that he, he was happy, meaning that like, he was like, I, I'm not really doing anything for the first time in a while. It's kind of great. I've just watched Alien and, and, and Blade Runner and we started talking about reading and books and stuff.
然后，然后他们不得不取消。所以当Willie生病时我开始发短信，他并没有真的生病，但他只是待在家里，然后我们，他开始谈论它，当我说他，他很高兴，意思是，他就像，我，我第一次在一段时间内什么都没做。这感觉真好。我刚看了《异形》和《银翼杀手》，我们开始谈论阅读和书籍之类的东西。
And it was just, I don't know, I just really connected. Yeah. It's incredible. Yeah. They've got some really great energy, very, very sweet. Incredible musicians. I mean, yeah, they're really great. I love, I love that song so much under the empire.
而且，我不知道，我真的很有共鸣。是的。太不可思议了。是的。他们有很棒的能量，非常非常甜。不可思议的音乐家。我是说，是的，他们真的很棒。我非常喜欢那首歌《The Empire》。
It's like, it sounds like an instant classic and it's off their new album, which is amazing. Yeah. It's off their new album. We, and it also, yeah, there are moments of it that sound like a Sergeant Pepper's. Yeah, for sure. And, you know, there's just, it's a great, that's a great song, you know, when you want to end something, you know, when you want to like say, you know, it's a really good for like, if you're going to bed, it's a really good lullab.
它听起来像是一首即时的经典，出自他们的新专辑，非常棒。是的。出自他们的新专辑。我们，而且它也，是的，其中有一些时刻听起来像《佩珀军士》。是的，肯定的。而且，你知道，这只是，这是一首很棒的歌，你知道，当你想要结束某件事时，你知道，当你想要说，你知道，这非常适合，如果你要睡觉，这是一首很好的摇篮曲。
Bye. Nice. Well. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast. Smart.
再见。不错。嗯。聪明。爆炸。聪明。爆炸。聪明。
Blast. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf and Bennett Barbicó. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
爆炸。SmartLess是由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf和Bennett Barbicó手工制作的100%有机节目。SmartLess。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。